JIM FRAZIER CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR COMING OUT AND TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING
TODAY. I AM VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THIS TURNOUT. I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE SUBMIT ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WALDRON. KEVIN MULLIN
IN JOSE MEDINA AND DOCTOR
SHIRLEY WEBER WHO SIT ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. AND A SPECIAL THANK YOU
TO EVERYONE ON THE GROUND HERE
IN THE CAPITAL WHO WORK SO HARD
TO PUT THIS HEARING TOGETHER.
THAT MEANS MILEAGES LATE OF AID
CHARLES TO LACK. THIS HEARING
IS BEING LIVE STREAMED TO THE
SELECT COMMITTEES PAGE ON THE
STATE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE AND TO
MY LEGISLATIVE FACEBOOK PAGE.
VIDEO OF THE ENTIRE HEARING
WILL BE ARCHIVED IN LINKED AT
THE SELECT COMMITTEE PAGE WITH
CLOSED CAPTIONING. VIDEO OF OUT
OF MOST OF OUR PREVIOUS
HEARINGS ARE ARCHIVED AT SELECT
COMMITTEE PAGE AS WELL AND
FUTURE HEARINGS WILL BE ALSO.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED I'D LIKE
TO HAVE MY COLLEAGUES SAY A FEW
WORDS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. I
WANT TO THANK THE- I CHAIR ALL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER FOR
ORGANIZING THIS- VERY IMPORTANT
MEETING TODAY- HE'S TRULY A
CHAMPION FOR THE DISABLED
COMMUNITY KEEPS US ALL FOCUSED
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
WHICH IS GREAT BECAUSE EVERY
GROUP NEEDS A CHAMPION AND I
REALLY THANK HIM FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP. AND FOR BRINGING US
ALL TOGETHER I THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR COMING BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S
QUITE A CHALLENGE TO GET TO THE
CAPITAL AND YET- OUR COMMUNITY
THAT THAT IS HERE- AND AS
ADVOCATES THAN PARTICIPANTS IN
THE DISABLED COMMUNITY- YOU
MAKE IT TO THE CAPITAL YOU MAKE
US AWARE OF WHAT'S GOING ON AND
I HOPE AT SOME POINT- WE- YOU
KNOW OUR APPRECIATION IN THE
KINDS OF WORK THAT WE DO AND
THE THINGS THAT WE TRY TO FIND
AND THE- CONVENIENCE IS THAT
THERE. IS SOUNDS LIKE AN
EXCITING- PANEL I'M INTERESTED
IN HEARING AND LEARNING MORE
FROM YOU SO THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR COMING IN THANKS TO A
CHEER FOR ORGANIZING PRECIADO.
MISTER MEDINA. WELL I. WANT TO
ECHO DOT WEBER THANK YOU TO OUR
CHAIR. OF MISTER FRAZIER FOR
PUTTING THIS- SELECT COMMITTEE.
TOGETHER THIS HEARING AND FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP THROUGHOUTTHE
YEARS- ON THIS TOPIC ON- ON.
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. HAVEN'T BEEN A
LONG TIME TEACHER. IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS- I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT WORK THAT- THIS
COMMITTEE IS DOING IS AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU SO THANK YOU ALSO FOR
BEING HERE AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO A VERY INFORMATIVE HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA AND
AGAIN THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING
HERE- I WILL SHARE WITH. OUR
AUDIENCE THAT- EARLY ON IN MY
CAREER IS AS A LEGISLATOR
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER SHE WAS THE FIRST ONE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE REINSTATEMENT
OF THE A BA. HI SO THAT I WILL
NEVER FORGET. YOU CAN APPLAUD
HER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE AGAIN TODAY BECAUSE
I'M YOU KNOW I'M THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND I AND
HELPING THE ID I DD COMMUNITY
I'LL GET THE SUPPORTED DESERVES
FROM THE STATE IS MY PASSION.
BUT THIS HEARING IS NOT ABOUT
ME OR MY COLLEAGUES WE ARE HERE
TO LISTEN TO YOU WE'RE HERE TO
DISCUSS THE CHALLENGES FACED BY
FAMILIES WHO LIVE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. I DD AFFECTS ALL
OF US REGULAR REGARDLESS OF OUR
BACKGROUND OR WHERE WE LIVE. R.
I. D. D. POPULATION CONTINUES
TO GROW AND WE MUST PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND SUPPORT
TO ARE IDG FRIENDS NEIGHBORS.
AND OUR FAMILY MEMBERS. OVER
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF I HELD
EIGHT SELECT COMMITTEE HEARINGS
ACROSS THIS JUST DIFFERENT
REGIONS OF THE STATE FROM SAN
DIEGO TO READING. SO IN
SACRAMENTO FRESNO CONCORD
RIVERSIDE READING EUREKA
COACHELLA AND SAN DIEGO. AND
WE'RE NOT DONE. THEY WERE GOING
TO BE SHARING WHAT WE'VE
DISCOVERED. UP TO DATE. WE'VE
LEARNED FROM FROM PREVIOUS
HEARINGS THAT LISTEN TO YOUR
STORIES IS THE MOST VALUABLE
THING WE'RE GOING TO DO TODAY.
WE HAVE SET ASIDE AMPLE TIME AT
THE END OF THE HEARING FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT TO HEAR FROM YOU.
OVER THE PAST YEAR THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN CONDUCTING
AN ONLINE SURVEY ABOUT REGIONAL
CENTERS. AT EACH HEARING I HAVE
ENCOURAGED EVERYONE TO COMPLETE
THE SURVEY WHICH CAN BE FOUND
ONLINE ARE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AT HE CONCLUSION OF LAST
YEAR'S HEARINGS WE SUBMITTED
THE ANONYMOUS DATA TO THE STATE
LIBRARY'S CALIFORNIA RESEARCH
BUREAU. AFTER READING THROUGH
THE REPORT WE DISCOVER THERE'S
A LOT OF ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT.
AND TRUST ME. WE WILL GET THERE.
THERE ARE COPIES OF THE SURVEY
RESULTS AVAILABLE TODAY IN THE
BACK OF THE ROOM. ALSO I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO INFORMED. SO
OKAY LET'S GET STARTED WE WILL
BEGIN THIS HEARING WITH A
PRESENTATION BY DOCTOR TONYA
BUSY SENIOR POLICY ANALYST WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESEARCH BUREAU.
DOCTOR. AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR TIRELESS WORK. PLEASE
PRESENT WE READY. TESTING OKAY.
THANK YOU CHAIR FRAZIER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
INVITATION AND STAFF FOR THE
INVITATION AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
HERE TODAY. I WILL KEEP MY
REMARKS AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE
AND I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS NOW OR AFTER THE
HEARING. MY NAME IS DOCTOR
TONYA DE LINDSEY AND I AM A
SENIOR RESEARCHER AT THE
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH BUREAU.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LIBRARY. I AM ALSO A PROFESSOR
RESEARCH METHODS AND STATISTICS
WE CSU CHICO WHERE I TEACH PART
TIME AS A LECTURER. CHAIR
FRAZIER STAFF ASK THE RESEARCH
BUREAU TO ANALYZE SURVEY DATA.
THEIR OFFICE COLLECTED ONLINE
AND IT'S SEVEN HEARINGS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FROM OCTOBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. TO DECEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN. THE SURVEY SOUGHT
INFORMATION FROM CLIENTS CARE
GIVERS AND PARENTS WHO UTILIZE
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT HAVE OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND CASES.
WE SUBMITTED OUR FINAL
MEMORANDUM. WITH SURVEY RESULTS
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY. THE SURVEY DATA WERE
COLLECTED USINGA CONVENIENCE
DATA COLLECTION METHOD WHICH
MEANS THE DATA WERE COLLECTED
FROM ANYONE WHO WANTED TO FILL
OUT THE SURVEY THERE WAS NOT A
SYSTEMATIC SAMPLING METHOD
INVOLVED IN DATA COLLECTION.
THE MOST SOUGHT AFTER SIR
SURVEY DATA COMES FROM A RANDOM
SAMPLE RATHER THAN A
CONVENIENCE SAMPLE BECAUSE
RANDOM SAMPLING ALLOWS FOR
STATISTICAL RESULTS. FROM A
SURVEY TO BE GENERALIZED AS
REPRESENTING THE POPULATION
STUDY. IDEALLY THE SURVEY WOULD
HAVE BEEN SENT TO A RANDOM
SAMPLE OF ALL CLIENTS CARE
GIVERS AND PARENTS OF REGIONAL
CENTERS. WELL STATISTICAL
RESULTS FROM SURVEYS- FROM THIS
SURVEY CANNOT BE GENERALIZED AS
REPRESENTING ALL CLIENTS CARE
GIVERS AND PARENTS WHO UTILIZE
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES. IT IS
A VALID REPRESENTATION OF THE
OPINIONS AND THOUGHTS OF THOSE
WHO DID COMPLETE THE SURVEY.
CONVENIENCE SAMPLING RESULTS
MAKE US AWARE OF WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO SURVEY RESPONDENTS
AND CAN OFFER GUIDANCE AS TO
WHAT MIGHT BE IMPORTANT TO THE
LARGER POPULATION. THERE WERE A
TOTAL OF SIX HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
TWO RESPONSES TO THE SURVEY.
AND TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
OR ABOUT 35% COMPLETED ALL OF
THE QUANTIFIABLE QUESTIONS. WE
ANALYZED ONLY THOSE TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE RESPONSES FOR
THE QUANTITATIVE ANALYSES FOR
THREE REASONS. ONE BECAUSE
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION WAS NOT
COLLECTED WE COULD NOT USE
ADDITIONAL METHODS TO PREDICT
THE MISSING DATA. TO RESULTS
ARE OFTEN IN RELATION TO ONE
ANOTHER. OFTEN WHEN VIEWING
STATISTICAL RESULTS COMPARISONS
ARE MADE DIFFERENT GROUPS OF
PEOPLE'S ANSWERS TO SIMILAR
QUESTIONS FOR EXAMPLE ASKING
ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE TO RANK
EXPERIENCE WITH CASE WORKERS
BUT ASKING ANOTHER GROUP OF
PEOPLE TO SAY HOW LONG IT
TAKES. A CARE GIVER TO RETURN A
CALL IS NOT COMPARABLE. A
READER MIGHT MISS THAT IT IS
TWO DIFFERENT GROUPS OF PEOPLE
BEING COMPARED AND MAKING A RUN
ITS CONCLUSION. THREE IN
ADDITION COMPARING SATISFACTION
ACROSS REGIONAL CENTERS WHEN
SOME RESPONDENTS FROM ONE
REGIONAL CENTER ANSWER ONE
QUESTION BUT NOT ANOTHER. DOES
NOT LEND ITSELF TO A FAIR
COMPARISON. THE INDICES WE
CONSTRUCTED FROM RESPONDENTS
ANSWERING QUESTIONS ASKING THEM
TO RANK THEIR CENTER SERVICES
AND SERVICE PROVISION. ARE
BASED ON THE TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE COMPLETED SURVEYS.
OVER HALF OF THE RESPONDENTS
REPORTED USING THE SAN DIEGO
INLAND ALTA EAST BAY AND VALLEY
MOUNTAIN REGIONAL CENTERS. NOT
REPRESENTED IN THE SAMPLE WAS
ANYONE FROM SAN GABRIEL OUR
POMONA ARE SAN GABRIEL POMONA.
IN THE OVERALL RANKING ON A
SCALE FROM ONE TO TEN
RESPONDENTS FROM FRANK T.
LANHAM AND RATED SERVICES AND
SERVICE PROVISION THEY'RE
HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER REGIONAL
CENTER. AND OVERALL THE
RESPONDENTS FROM FRANKIE LANA
MEN KERN VALLEY VALLEY
MOUNTAIN. REDWOOD COAST SAN
DIEGO ALTA EAST BAY AND GOLDEN
GATE RANGE THEIR REGIONAL
CENTERS ABOVE THE AVERAGE
RATING FOR ALL CENTERS. IT MAY
BE USEFUL MOVING FORWARD TO
LOOK FURTHER INTO THESE
LOCATIONS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
MADE SOME PEOPLE RANK THESE
CENTERS HIGHLY. AND FOR THOSE
RESPONDENTS WHO ASKED FOR
FOLLOW AT AN PROVIDED CONTACT
INFORMATION MORE IN DEPTH
INFORMATION COULD BE COLLECTED
IF NEEDED. IN ADDITION TO THOSE
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
COMPLETED SURVEYS ANALYZED
USING STATISTICAL SUMMARIES.
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHT NEARLY
60% OF THAT OF THE SIX HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY RESPONDENTS LEFT
SOMETIMES LENGTHY COMMENTS IN
ANSWER TO AN OPEN ENDED
QUESTION. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SHARE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
REGARDING YOUR INTERACTION WITH
THE REGIONAL CENTER. IT IS TO
THESE QUALITATIVE DATA I TURN
TO NOW TO SHARE THE RESULTS OF
A THEMATIC ANALYSIS OF THOSE
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHT
COMMENTS. A THEMATIC ANALYSIS
UNLIKE STATISTICS OFFERS MORE
IN DEPTH ANALYSIS OF
RESPONDENTS REPORTED
EXPERIENCES. SOME OF THE
COMMENTS FORTY FIVE WERE VERY
POSITIVE AND EIGHTY WERE MIXED
AND WE TOOK THOSE TO BE
INSTRUCTIVE OF WHAT RESPONDENTS
WANT TO SEE MORE OF. THERE WERE
FOUR POSITIVE THEMES THAT
EMERGED FROM THE ANALYSIS.
FIRST CLIENT CARE GIVERS AND
PARENTS EMPHASIZED HOW
IMPORTANT SERVICES IMPROPER
ASSESSMENT AND DIAGNOSIS ARE TO
THEIR HIGH SATISFACTION WITH
THE REGIONAL CENTER. LISTEN TO
WHAT ONE RESPONDENT ROAD AS
THEY RELATE THEIR STRUGGLE WITH
GETTING A DIAGNOSIS FOR THEIR
DAUGHTER UNTIL A REGIONAL
CENTER FINALLY HELPED THEM. MY
CHILD SHE THEY SAID AGE TWENTY
FIVE WAS JUST APPROVED FOR
SERVICES WITHIN THE LAST MONTH.
IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLY
OVERWHELMING FOR ME STRUGGLING
ON MY OWN ALL THESE YEARS NEVER
HAVING RECEIVED AN APPROPRIATE
DIAGNOSIS FROM A MEDICAL DOCTOR
OR THERAPIST OR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. SHE HAD BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH SEVERAL OTHER
DISORDERS SINCE THE AGE OF
NINE. SO THE DIAGNOSIS REALLY
HELPS TO UNDERSTAND HER
INABILITY TO FUNCTION IN LIFE.
I FEEL MUCH BETTER THAN I AM
NOW GETTING HELP THE PEOPLE
THAT REDWOOD COAST REGIONAL
CENTER HAVE BEEN GREAT. THEY
SAID. SECOND SOME RESPONDENTS
DESCRIBED FEELING LIKE FAMILY
WITH THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
REPORT WORKING TOGETHER AS A
TEAM. BUILDING CLOSE FAMILY
LIKE RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
PEOPLE REGIONAL CENTER SERVE IS
APPRECIATED BY THOSE WHO HAVE
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS. THIRD
RESPONDENTS INDICATED THEY
APPRECIATE MEETING GOALS
THROUGH GUIDANCE TEAM WORK AND
SUPPORT. CLIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES REPORT BEING GOAL
ORIENTED AND APPRECIATING WHEN
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF HELP THEM
REACH THEIR GOALS. AND FINALLY
COMMUNICATION IS KEY. FOR
POSITIVE INTERACTIONS WITH
REGIONAL CENTERS RESPONDENTS
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THERE
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE CHANGING
AND GETTING BETTER AT THINGS
THEY LIKE REGIONAL CENTERS TO
DO SUCH AS LISTEN RESPOND AND
SHARE INFORMATION. IN
COMPARISON TO THE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE COMMENTS THAT
POSITIVE OR MIXED COMMENTS.
RESPONDENTS ROAD APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY NEGATIVE
COMMENTS WE FOUND THE NEGATIVE
COMMENTS TO GROUP AROUND THE
FOLLOWING SIX THEMES THAT
SUGGEST NEEDED CHANGES FROM THE
RESPONDENTS POINTS OF VIEW. ONE
RESPONDENTS BELIEVE REGIONAL
CENTERS COULD IMPROVE THE
PROVISION OF ACCURATE
INFORMATION IN A TIMELY AN
CONSISTENT MANNER. SOME
RESPONDENTS INDICATED THEY ARE
GIVEN INCORRECT INFORMATION OR
LEADS TO THAT SOME STAFF HAVE
PURPOSELY NOT GIVEN THEM THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED. FOR
EXAMPLE SOMEWHERE MORE GENERAL
BY WRITING THINGS LIKE I WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT
SERVICES PROVIDED TO ALL AND A
CONSISTENT LIST OF AVAILABLE
SERVICES. OTHERS WERE VERY
SPECIFIC AND WROTE THINGS SUCH
AS I SUGGEST THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE FORM
AN ALLIANCE WITH HOSPITALS TO
EDUCATE NEW PARENTS OF BABIES
BORN WITH DISABILITIES OF THEIR
EXISTENCE. THIS INFORMATION
SHOULD ALSO BE MADE AVAILABLE
TO NEW RESIDENT PACKAGES AN IN
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
COMMUNICATE SO NO ONE IS LEFT
OUT. THE SECOND THEME IN THE
NEGATIVE COMMENTS. IS REGIONAL
CENTERS NEED MORE AND SKILLED
AND KNOWLEDGEABLE AND CARING
STAFF AND SERVICE PROVIDERS.
MANY OF THE RESPONDENTS
COMMENTED ABOUT HIGH STAFF
TURNOVER AND THE FRUSTRATION OF
FEELING LIKE THEY HAVE TO START
OVER EVERY TIME THEY RECEIVE A
NEW CASE WORKER. RESPONDENTS
LIKE THIS ONE COMMENTED ON THE
CASE LOADS AND PAY FOR THE
STAFF. THEY SAID SINCE OUR CASE
WORKER HAS I BELIEVE OVER A
HUNDRED CLIENTS I WOULD LIKE G.
G. R. C. TO HIRE MORE CASE
WORKERS. AND ANOTHER WROTE DDS
SHOULD RAISE THE STANDARDS OF
TRAINING AND RATES OF PAY IN
ORDER TO CREATE A STABLE
RELIABLE AND WELL TRAINED
WORKFORCE. AND THEY THINK
VENDORS SHOULD BE PAID MORE
THIS PERSON WROTE. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT FUNDING IS
INCREASED FOR ALL VENDORS
INVOLVED WITH THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY WE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
BIG SCRAPE AND WONDER WHAT MORE
WE COULD BE DOING FOR SPECIAL
LEFT ONCE. THEN THERE ARE
FAMILIES TO GET NOTHING BECAUSE
THEY ARE UNAWARE OF THE
EXISTENCE AND PROCESS OF
REGIONAL CENTERS AND THEIR
SERVICES. THE THIRD THEME IS
THAT PAYMENTS AND FUNDING
GENERALLY. ARE CITED AS
PROBLEMS BY RESPONDENTS. SOME
REPORTED NOT BEING REIMBURSED
WELL OTHER SUGGESTED THE
OVERALL SYSTEM NEEDED NEEDS
MORE FUNDING. WARS OR A
COMPLETE OVERHAUL. ONE
RESPONDENT EVEN SUGGESTED
ELIMINATING REGIONAL CENTERS.
WHILE OTHER SAID THAT MORE
MONEY OR FUNDING COULD HELP AND
WROTE IT IS NOT MY IMPRESSION
THAT THE REGIONAL CENTER IS THE
PROBLEM WHERE THERE ARE ISSUES
BUT THAT THERE ISN'T ENOUGH
MONEY IN THE SYSTEM. PROGRAMS
THAT CLOSED AFTER ALL THE
BUDGET CUTS HAVE NOT BEEN
REPLACED AND THERE ARE JUST NOT
ENOUGH OPENINGS FOR EVERYONE
WHO HAS NEEDS. THE FOUR THEME.
IS THAT RESPONDENTS WROTE THAT
REGIONAL CENTERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS SHOULD BE TRANSPARENT
AND HELD ACCOUNTABLE THROUGH
OVERSIGHT. POLICY IN LAW NEED
TO BE EXAMINED AND FOLLOWED.
SEVERAL RESPONDENTS EXPRESSED A
NEED FOR MORE OVERSIGHT OF
THEIR REGIONAL CENTER AND
REPORTED EXERTING GREAT
PERSONAL EFFORT. TO ENSURE
REGIONAL CENTER COMPLIANCE WITH
LAWS SUCH AS THE FRANK THE
LANHAM ACT. ONE RESPOND IT READ
AT LENGTH I KEEP IT SHOR. THE
REGIONAL CENTER DEMONSTRATES A
DISREGARD FOR CLIENTS RIGHTS
AND THE RULE OF LAW THEY SAID.
THEY REFUSE TO FOLLOW THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAWJUDGE'S
RULING IN MY SISTER'S FAIR
HEARING CASE AND THERE IS
LITTLE I CAN DO ABOUT IT. THE
R. C. ABUSES THEIR POWER AND IS
NOT ACCOUNTABLE TO ANYBODY IT
IS TIME FOR REFORM. AND THE
FIFTEEN IS THAT RESPONDENTS
BELIEVE A ACCESS TO SERVICES
NEEDS TO BE EXPANDED.
RESPONDENTS ASKED FOR MORE
RESPITE CARE FINANCIAL LEGAL
TRANSPORTATION EMERGENCY
PLACEMENTS AND SERVICES
EMPLOYMENT LONG TERM CARE AND
HOUSING SERVICES. SOME
RESPONDENTS WANT SERVICES
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE THINGS SUCH
AS SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WITH
FETAL ALCOHOL SYNDROME. AND
FINALLY A THEME THAT SURFACED
IS CONCERNS ABOUT POTENTIAL
BIAS IN THE AWARD AND DELIVERY
OF SERVICES SOME RESPONDENTS
REPORTED THAT QUOTE HISPANIC
NON WHITE AND NON ENGLISH
SPEAKER CLIENTS AND QUOTE. HAVE
A PARTICULARLY TOUGH TIME
GETTING SERVICES. ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION IS VALUABLE EVEN
FROM A CONVENIENCE SAMPLE IN
FUTURE SURVEYS IT WOULD BE
USEFUL TO KNOW IF THE
RESPONDENT AS A CLIENT CARE
GIVER APPARENT. AND TO
CAREFULLY CHOOSE THE SAMPLE TO
BE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE LARGER
POPULATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMERS. AS WELL AS TO
STRUCTURE QUESTIONS SO THE
RESPONDENTS ANSWER ALL OF THE
QUESTIONS. THAT SAID THE
INFORMATION GARNERED FROM THE
CURRENT SURVEY MAY BE
INSTRUCTIVE FOR THIS COMMITTEE.
TO SUMMARIZE THE THEMATIC
ANALYSIS IN TERMS OF WHAT
RESPONDENTS INDICATED COULD
HELP IMPROVE HOW REGIONAL
CENTERS SERVE CLIENTS CARE
GIVERS AND PARENTS ONE. EXAMINE
AND OVERSEE PROCESS SEES AND
LEGAL COMPLIANCE OVER TIME. TO
EXAMINE OVERSEE AND POSSIBLY
CHANGE THE ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE OF READ REGIONAL
CENTERS. THREE INCREASED
AVAILABILITY OF SERVICES. FOR
INCREASED FUNDING FOR VENDORS
AND SERVICES. FIVE INCREASE
FUNDING FOR STAFF AND TRAINING
TO RETAIN EXPERIENCED STAFF.
SIX IDENTIFY WAYS TO COORDINATE
INFORMATION AND ACCESS. MAKE
MORE SEVEN AND LAST MAKE MORE
INFORMATION EASILY AVAILABLE
FOR CLIENTS PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS WE THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
THAT ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE- DR. THANK YOU
GREAT REPORT A LOT OF
INFORMATION- JUST QUICKLY
REGARDING THE INFORMATION ABOUT
SERVICES AVAILABLE IT SEEMS
LIKE THAT WAS KIND OF AN
OVERRIDING THING ABOUT HIS
COMMENTS- HOW MUCH DO THEY DO
ONLINE I MEAN IS THERE WITHIN
THE REGIONAL CENTERS CAN THE
FAMILIES GO ONLINE AND GET
INFORMATION OR IS THAT NOT AN
OPTION IT DIDN'T FROM JUST THE
COMMENTS I READ THEY DID NOT
MENTION GOING ONLINE THEY
ACTUALLY ASKED FOR MORE
SERVICES TO BE AVAILABLE ON
ONLINE SUCH AS MENUS. OKAY YEAH
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS OF
NOTES THAT NOT KNOWING ABOUT
SERVICES OR THAT THEY NEED TO
TRAVEL SOME DISTANCE IN ORDER
TO GET THE GET THE SERVICES
THEY GET INFORMATION EVEN THAT
SEEMS TO BE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT MIGHT THE OTHER THING IS
WAS IS THERE A WAY TO TELL FROM
THE RESPONSES IF- SOME OF THE-
SOME OF THE RESPONSES WERE
RELATIVE TO A CERTAIN CENTER.
YOU KNOW VAST SAYS JUST ALL
OVER THE STATE IT THAT I
COULDN'T I COULDN'T SPEAK TO NO
I COULDN'T MATCH THE ALL THOSE
COMMENTS THEY DIDN'T
NECESSARILY EVEN WRITE THE
CENTER NECESSARILY IN FOR THE
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHT COMMENTS
YEAH THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS DOCTOR. WHAT WOULD
YOU SEE. OUR FOR FUTURE SURVEYS
HAVE YOU TOGETHER ARE YOU ABOUT
THAT TO MAKE IT. SO THAT THE
SURVEY THIS IS GOOD IN FOR. AS
POINTED OUT OF NEW TO OUR
PARTICULAR SO. TO IMPROVE WHAT
YOU SUGGEST WE DO IS IT FOR
SURVEYS FOR THIS. IF THERE WERE
AND NOW SURVEY EVEN A
PARTICULAR CENTER I THINK THAT
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS TO DO IS TO HAVE A FULL
LIST OF ALL OF THE PEOPLE TO
CONTACT AND THEN GET A RANDOM
SAMPLE FROM THOSE PEOPLE. BUT
WHATEVER YOU WOULD WANT TO ASK
THEM. OKAY SO BASICALLY GO
THROUGH THE CENTERS AND ASK
WHAT THEY THINK WOULD BE AND
GET A LIST OF WHO THEY ARE OR
WHO THEY'RE PROVIDING GET THE
CONTACT LIST IF WITH A
PROVIDING CARE FOR. IF YOU WANT
TO GO WITH THE- THE PERSON
GETTING CARE AS WELL AS THE
PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS. WOULD
START WITH A COMPLETE LIST
THERE OKAY ARE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. VETERANS IF YOU
SO VERY MUCH AD I KNOW THIS
WAS A ON A TASK OF COMPILING
ALL OF THIS DIFFERENT IF COME
IN- IT OVER ONE MY STAFF YOU
ACTUALLY SAVE THE DAY YEAH. NO
AND AGAIN WE HAD THIS COMMITTEE
TO. A HEARING TO PUT TOGETHER A
IN THIS WAS JUST ONE OF THE
LARGEST PARTS THAT- YOUR
EXPERTISE CAME AND SO VERY
HANDY AND WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP AND- AND
YOUR SUGGESTIONS ARE WARRANTED
WILL WORK WITH EDS AND REGIONAL
CENTERS TO. OR MORE
COMPREHENSIVE- APPROACH PER
REGIONAL CENTER. THANK YOU
WE'RE HAPPY TO SERVE. THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH. TWO NOW THAT. OF
THIS WALL HIS HOUSE IS GONNA
ASK IF YOU WANT TO SAVE REAL I
DIDN'T BOTH MEMBERS HAD A
CHANCE SOMETHING I WONDERED
KNOWLEDGE PLEASE THANK YOU KNOW
WAS A GOOD ENDEAVOR TO DO THE
SURVEY- I ACTUALLY DID A COUPLE
OF ARTICLES IN MY LOCAL
NEWSPAPERS- WITH THE SURVEY
LINK SO THAT YOU KNOW TO GET
OUT THERE MORE AND I THINK WE
DID IT TWICE OVER THE COURSE OF
THE TIME. SO HOPEFULLY THAT
HELPED AND YOU KNOW IF WE DO
SOMETHING ELSE IT'S A GOOD WAY
TO GET IT OUT YOU KNOW AND ARE
IN NO DISTRICTS SO. I WANT YOU
TO THANK EACH AND EVERY YOU
AGAIN THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN
LEVELS SELECT COMMITTEES WERE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY. TAKE THE TIME
TO SHOW UP BECAUSE WE DON'T
LEGISLATORS.AND BUT IT IS ON A
LISTENING- OPPORTUNITY TO. OF
HOW WE CAN BETTER SERVE THE
POPULATIONS OF AGAIN. HERE'S
YOUR CHANCE THANK YOU. WE MOVE
ON TO A PERRANCE PURSED PANEL
DISCUSSION WITH READY NOT
MAKING BILL AND ALEXIS TO RUN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RANDY
NOT I AM A PARENT OF A
WONDERFUL HUMAN BEING HIS NAME
IS PRESLEY NOT AND HE QUICKLY
INFORMED ME THAT HE COULD NOT
JOIN ME TODAY BECAUSE HE WOULD
MISS SCHOOL AND THAT WAS
UNACCEPTABLE. YOU GET IT ZERO.
OUT BUT I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE
OF WORKING WITH ASSEMBLYMAN
FRAZIER. AND ACTUALLY SOME OF
YOU IN MY PROFESSIONAL THINGS
I'VE EITHER LOBBIED YOU ON
HOUSING OR WATER OR FOR THE
CITY SACRAMENTO. I AM IN THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE BY TRADE-
NOT MORE THOUGH- BUT- NOT
EVERYBODY IS MY SON IS A
SUCCESS STORY WHEN WE WERE WHEN
HE WAS TWO. WE WERE TOLD THAT
THIS BEAUTIFUL CHILD WOULD
NEVER SPEAK NEVER POTTY TRAIN
WE SHOULD SET UP A SUPPORTED
LIVING ACCOUNT AND LET HIM AS
HE IS. AND WE WENT AHEAD AND
WENT TO THE REGIONAL CENTER
AND- DIGESTED ALL OF THIS WELL-
HE DOESN'T SHUT UP. HE'S
PERFECTLY POTTY TRAINED AND HE
WANTS TO BE STEPHEN COLE BEAR
OR TREVOR NOAH. SO WE'RE
FEELING PRETTY GOOD ABOUT THAT
THAT SAID. THE AMOUNT OF
SERVICES. WERE KEY TO HIS. AND
AS HE GETS OLDER WE ARE ONCE
AGAIN AT A CROSSROADS WHERE
THINGS ARE NOT TYPICAL. NOW
WHAT IS DEFINITELY NOT TYPICAL
IS THAT ONCE MY SON WAS
DIAGNOSED I GOT APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER AND
LATER BY GOVERNOR BROWN. TO THE
STATE COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES I SAT ON THE áREA
BOARD I BECAME VICE CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE SO OF
COURSE I KNEW EVERYTHING. I
DON'T I ENGLISH IS MY FIRST
LANGUAGE I'M NOT A PERSON OF
COLOR. I DID NOT NEED MEDI CAL
I DID NOT HAVE OTHER CHILDREN
TO WORRY ABOUT NOR A MINIMUM
WAGE JOB. THEY KEPT ME FROM
CONSTANTLY ADVOCATING- MY SON
IS A CLIENT AT- ALTER REGIONAL
CENTER. THE DIFFERENCE IN
ALTHOUGH OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS IS PHENOMENAL- IT IN ITS
IMPROVEMENT. IN MY EXPERIENCE
HOWEVER FOR THE HUNDRED PLUS
FAMILIES- FOR WHOM I ATTENDED
EITHER I EAT PEAS AT THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS I. P. P.'S. AT
ALL THE I MEET THE MAN TRADER
JOE'S THEY'RE MY FRIENDS
COUSINS BROTHERS CHILD I GO
JUST TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
UNIVERSE THAT THE ORIGINAL
DIAGNOSIS WAS NOT CORRECT. THEY
DON'T HAVE THE SAME EXPERIENCE.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHO TO CALL MR
BUT NAY- IT USED TO BE THAT WE
HAD ADVOCATES AT THE AREA
BOARDS. WHO WOULD COME IN AND
STEP IN MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT NO LONGER IS AVAILABLE- IF
I WERE YOU KNOW IF I WERE TO
SAY. WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE-
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IS THE
COMMUNICATION IS ABSOLUTELY
KEY. BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE A
WATCHDOG THESE ARE STILL NON
PROFITS PROVIDING STATE
SERVICES. AND THAT PIECE IS
MISSING. AND THERE NEEDS TO BE
BETTER LINKAGE BETWEEN. SCHOOL
BOARDS SCHOOL DISTRICTS. POLICY
IN EDUCATION AND POLICY IN THE
ID DE AREA BECAUSE BECAUSE-
WHAT OFTEN HAPPENS I SEEM THAN
ANY. IS SCHOOL SAYING THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND OF THAT
AND THEN THE REGIONAL SO IS NO
THIS. IN CHARGE OF THAT. AND
DURING THAT TIME THAT CHILD IS
LOSING SERVICES AND LOSING A
CHANCE. TO BE A PRODUCTIVE
MEMBER OF OUR SOCIETY IN THE
ONLY STATE WITH AN ENTITLEMENT
FOR PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. SO I WOULD- AGAIN
REITERATE EVERYTHING WE'VE
HEARD FROM FROM THE SURVEY BUT
ALSO LOOK TO A WAY TO RESOLVE
THIS TO ENSURE THAT EVERYBODY'S
GETTING. A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
SERVICES A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
COMMUNICATION I'M SORRY I'M
QUITE SAVVY THE LOT THE WEBSITE
IS UNACCEPTABLE. IT'S UNUSABLE
IT DOESN'T HELP YOU AND YOU
DON'T KNOW- SO THE ALSO HAVING
A REGIONAL CENTER PERSON
AVAILABLE TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
IN GENERAL WOULD BE HUGE TO
CHECK THEM ON WHEN THEY CLAIM
THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S THAT
BELONGS. OUT WITH THE DISTRICT
VERSES THE RC AND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PLACES THIS HITS IS
WITH OUR LARGEST POPULATION
WHICH YOUR KIDS ON THE AUTISM
SPECTRUM. BECAUSE THERE IS IT
IS THE NEWEST THING THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH AND IT IS THE MOST
THING THAT WE ARE DEALING WITH.
AND IT IS THE EASIEST PLACE FOR
KIDS TO GET LOST IN THE SHUFFLE
BECAUSE EVERYTHING SEEMS
ACADEMIC OR EVERYTHING SEEMS.
YOU'RE RELATED TO LIFE SKILLS
THERE'S GRAY AREAS SO WITH
THAT- I WOULD. RICK THAT WE
LOOK AT REDUCING MISTER FRAZIER
BILL FROM LACK YEAR WE GIVE OF
MORE POWER THE PARENTS MORE
POWERS. TO THE AREA BOARDS TO
KIND OF BALANCE THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND OF COURSE THE
TRAINING I OF THE BEST SERVICE
COORDINATOR IN THE WORLD SHE
WOULD GET FIRED IF I SAID OUT
LOUD THAT SHE IS MANAGED TO
STAY WITH MY SON SINCE BEFORE
USED TO. ANY SEVENTEEN NOW
THAT'S A VERY SPECIAL HUMAN
BEING I'M VERY FORTUNATE. OTHER
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THAT AND
THAT'S NOT OKAY. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. MS BELL. I'M AN ANALYST
RANDI'S HELP HERE REAL QUICK. I
THINK IT'S TIME FOR WHEN YOU
PUT A FACE WITH THE NAME OF.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
CHAIR FOR THE INVITED ME TO
THAT TOO- FOR INVITING ME AND
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I APOLOGIZE THIS IS
DEEPLY PERSONALLY FEEL SILLY
CRYING. AS I'VE TALKED TO
THOUSAND OF LITTLE LEAGUERS AND
THIS JUST SOMEHOW I THINK THIS.
I'M GO FIGURE. OKAY SO I'M I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU TO MY
UNIVERSE THE USER TO THE A MOST
PART MEN IN MY WORLD. TO MY
RIGHT IS DEREK MY YOUNGEST HE
WAS BORN WITH A RARE DISEASE
THE PRESENTS WITH MYSTIC MINI
DISC- MANY DEBILITATING TRAITS.
HE WILL BE SIXTEEN NEXT MONTH
IT IS AN ALL SPORT ATHLETE.
COMPETING IN HIGH SCHOOL
UNIFIED SPORTS AT FREEDOM HIGH
SCHOOL IN OKLEE. HE IS MISTER
SOCIAL AND GIRL CRAZY AND
ACTIVE IN JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING
ON CAMPUS. ON MY LEFT IS MY
OLDEST. EXACT ISN'T ACTIVE DUTY
U. S. NAVY CORPSMAN CURRENTLY
STATIONED AT TWENTY NINE PALMS
A GRADUATE OF FREEDOM HIGH
SCHOOL CLASS OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND FORMER DISTANCE
RUNNER HE LOVES SERVING HIS
COUNTRY AND ESPECIALLY
PROTECTING THOSE WHO CANNOT
PROTECT THEMSELVES. I AM
INCREDIBLY PROUD OF BOTH MY
BOYS. WHEN DEREK WAS BORN IN IN
THE YEARS THAT FOLLOWED I MADE
THE PROMISE TO BOTH BOYS THAT I
WOULD SECURE WHATEVER SUPPORT
IS AVAILABLE AND HAVE SERVICES
IN PLACE SO WHAT WHEN THE CARE
TRANSFERS FROM ME TO THE ARC
THEY BOTH WOULD BE IN GOOD
SHAPE. ASSEMBLY FRAZIER. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I SEE
HER BEFORE YOU BROKEN.
INITIALLY AND TO ANNOUNCE ALLOW
THE I FAILED. REFERRED TO
REGIONAL CENTER AT AGE DEAR
RECEIVED EARLIER SERVICES AT
THE WAY CENTER. AT THE
PITTSBURGH OKAY. UNABLE WALK WE
WOULDN'T BE BROKEN SINCE IN THE
CASE HOMELESS EVERY INTO THE
GATES HIS CLASS. THERE HE
RECEIVED MUCH NEEDED SOME AND
GUIDANCE STOP AS- DONE BY ALL
REELING FOR. THE PROCESS WAS
OVER ONE A FAST THE CURRENT OF
CASE. EARLY IN A AND THE BILL
SERVICES MADE MY HEAD SPIN. DAY
TO DAY CAN ON TEACHING ONE WELL
BUT IT BECAME VERY CLEAR. ALONG
WITH LENGTHY MEDICAL DIED AND
EDUCATE SUPPORT. THAT LEARNING
TO THE REASONING REGIONAL
SYSTEM WAS GOING TO BE A WHOLE
NOTHER BEAST I WAS ASKED
QUESTIONS LIKE WHAT DO I WANT
FOR MY CHILD. WHAT IS IMPORTANT
TO MY CHILD MY IMMEDIATE
REACTION FINANCES CAME EASY I
WANT HIM TO BE LOVED AND I WANT
HIM TO BE HAPPY. OKAY CAME THE
REPLY A SERVICE PLAN WAS
WRITTEN AND WE WERE SENT ON OUR
WAY. I WAS WONDERING WHAT IT
HAPPENED EVERYONE WAS NICE
ENOUGH. BUT I WAS LEFT WITH THE
THING PCKING STOMACH. THAT I
JUST MISSED SOMETHING BIG. BUT
I HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH. THAT
THERE WAS MAYBE SHORT MORE THAT
I SHOULD HAVE ASKED FOR SOMEHOW.
WHAT MORE IS THERE OTHER THAN
LEVIN HAPPINESS. I WOULD
PAINFULLY LEARNED THAT THERE
WAS MUCH MUCH MORE. GENTLE
COACHING FROM STAFF AND SHE'S
RETIRED NOW SO I CAN SAY THIS
BUT EVEN MISS LANKFORD HERSELF
TAKING HER DIRECTOR HAD OFF.
AND INSTEAD SPEAKING TO WAS ME
TO HIS MOM SPEAKING TO ME AS A
MOM OPEN MY EYES ALL THE THINGS
I NEED TO ASK. THAT I HAD TO
ASK FOR OR DEREK WOULDN'T EVEN
BEGIN TO RECEIVE A FRACTION OF
WHAT HE NEEDED. VERY QUICKLY I
LEARNED THAT NO ONE NO ONE WAS
GOING TO HELP ME KNOW WHAT HE
TRULY NEEDED. HOW COULD THAT BE
ISN'T THAT WITH THIS CASE
MEASURE WAS FOR TO HELP GUIDE
US. ALWAYS A BELIEVER AND REYES
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION WHEN
YOU PRESENT A PROBLEM. I AM
BROUGHT TO STOPS TENSION THE
FILTH MERE FEET AWAY FROM THE
CHILDREN THAT ALL CAME TO THE
EARLY INTERVENTION CLASS. NO
ONE TOOK ME SERIOUSLY UNTIL
AFTER THE WITNESS ME DAILY FOR
A WEEK. BACKING UP THE BOTTLES
AND NEEDLES WELL THE CHILDREN
WERE IN SCHOOL. LITTLE DID I
KNOW AT THE TIME TAKING ACTION
WHEN NO ONE ELSE WOULD BECAME A
RESOUNDING THEME OF MY LIFE.
FAST FORWARD TO POP SCHOOL. THE
INTERNET OF IP SCHOOL C. NOT BE
REGIONAL SERVER. EVEN MORE AND
WORKING WITH THE CASE MANAGER
THE SAID NO OR I DON'T KNOW
MORE THAN SHE EVER SAID YES.
FRUSTRATIONS MOUNTED THIS A
SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL POINT TO
THE REGIONAL CENTER AND
REGIONAL CENTER WITH POINT BACK.
SPRINKLING MOUNTING HEALTH
ISSUES AND MULTIPLE DOCTORS IT
WAS LIKE THREE FULL TIME JOBS.
IN THERE ARE WOVEN AMONG THE
SMALL QUIET MOMENTS WE TRIED TO
CELEBRATE JUST BE A KID. YEAR
AFTER YEAR OLD BY NO GUIDANCE
FROM REGIONAL CENTER NO
EFFECTIVE MEANINGFUL SERVICES I
REMEMBER THAT FEELING IT WAS
BACK. IT WAS BACK WITH A
VENGEANCE THE MORE EDUCATED
MYSELF AND THE MORE I CONNECTED
WITH PARENTS LIKE ME THE MORE I
LEARNED MY CASE MANAGER DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT MY SON NEEDED. SHE
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT WAS
AVAILABLE OR HOW TO CHECK. I
JUST GOT NO AND I DON'T KNOW.
WELL AT THIS POINT I HAD
INVOLVED AS A PARENT IN
ADDITION TO BECOMING A MEDICAL
EXPERT IN ALL AREAS MY SON
NEEDED I REALLY CALIFORNIA AT
CODE AT NIGHT I SAID ENOUGH. I
WASN'T GOING TO DO THE CASE
MANAGERS JOB AS WELL. SO I
REQUEST HER SUPERVISOR AN
ASPIRIN NEW MORE EXPERIENCED
REGIONAL CENTER MANAGER A
REGIONAL CENTER CASE MANAGER.
IT WASN'T FOR LACK OF. BEING A
NICE PERSON BUT IT WAS FOR LACK
OF EXPERIENCE AND I NEED TO
SOMEONE WHO KNEW MORE. YOU
WOULD THOUGHT THAT I WAS
SEEKING TO AND FROM THE QUEEN
MOTHER HERSELF MULTIPLE
MEETINGS IN AND DURING THREATS
OF ELIMINATION OF SERVICES I
WAS FINALLY ASSIGNED ANOTHER
CASE MANAGER. THAT CASE
MEASURES THE NEW. WAS LEERY OF
ME. I'VE BEEN LABELED THAT
PARENTS IT TOOK ONE CANDID SIT
DOWN MEETING WITH HER IN PERSON
AND SHE COMPLETELY GOT THE
PICTURE. SERVICES THAT ENSUED
DIAPERS FOR HIS INCONTINENCE IN
HOME THERAPY RESPITE. BY THAT
TIME WHEN SERVICES BY WE
ARRIVED. WE HAVE A BELLY FOR
THREE YEARS. FOR THE NEXT YEAR
TO. IT WAS ACTUALLY THERE I SAY
IT PEACEFUL. IT WAS A GOOD
THING BECAUSE DEREK TELLS
HEALTH TOOK A TURN FOR THE
WORSE ANDWE NEARLY LOST IN
THREE SEPARATE TIMES OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS. AND THE
INEVITABLE CHANGE I JUST NEVER
REALIZED HOW MUCH CHANGE THERE
WOULD BE. HIS CASE MANAGER WITH
MOVING TO BIGGER AND BETTER
THINGS WHICH GIVEN THE CALIBER
OF HER SUPPORT WAS NOT
SURPRISING SHE HAD BEEN AMAZING.
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS START
DEREK GET BOUNCED FROM CASE
MANAGER TO CASE MANAGER
SOMETIMES THERE WOULD BE
WRITTEN NOTIFICATION OFTEN NOT.
USUALLY I WOULD HEAR FROM
ANOTHER PARENT OCCASIONALLY I
WOULD HEAR FROM THE CURRENT
CASE MANAGER IN A PHONE CALL.
ONE DAY I'D HAD ENOUGH YET
AGAIN I WAS BEING NOTIFIED THAT
THIS CASE MANAGER WAS CHANGING.
THIS TIME I NO. CALLED IN IN.
THAT I ABLE TO SEE TO US. DO
YOU REMEMBER THAT CASE MANAGER
THAT I SAID NO OR I KNOW. THE
ONE THAT WAS NICE ENOUGH BUT IT
BEEN OVER HER HEAD AND WE BOTH
KNEW IT. SHE WAS. IRONICALLY
NOW IN TURN OF THE- I LOVE
MULTIPLE MESSAGES REQUESTING A
MEETING TO DISCUSS MY CONCERNS.
TO TRY AND FIND STABILITY. WELL
THERE WAS NO REPLY BUT THEN
FINALLY ONE. I RECEIVED A
LETTER STATING THAT BECAUSE I
HAD TO CLIMB SERVICES DEREK WAS
BEING DUMPED. I'LL BE HONEST
WITH YOU ALL THIS MEDICAL NEEDS
GOING I'M FULL TIME CARE GIVING
I WAS BEAT. THAT WAS THREE
YEARS AGO. THERE IS CONDITION
NO SENSE WORSENED. AND I
CONTINUED I THINK. FROM HIM THE
KICKER. NOT ONLY HAD THE MAN
FELT FLY BECAUSE ALL THOSE YOU
PRIOR WHEN I REQUESTED A MARKS
PER. AND IT ALSO REFUSE TO MEET
WITH ME REGARDING MY STERN
CONCERNS WHEN I WAS BEING HOW
GET ANOTHER CASE MANAGER. SHE
THEN PROCEEDED TO EARLY HIS
PRIDE. BY SHARING. BUT TO THIS
CASE WITH OTHER PARENTS. BY
NAME USING HIS NAME. AND THERE
WERE SO DRAW. WERE MADE
REGARDING ME BECAUSE REMEMBER I
HAD BEEN THAT PARENT. I AM NOT
HERE BUT YOU BECAUSE I CARE A
WHAT YOU OR ANYONE ELSE THINKS
OF ME. I AM HERE BECAUSE CHANGE
MUST HAPPEN I'M HERE BECAUSE
THERE ARE A LOT OF PARENTS LIKE
ME. I'M HERE BECAUSE OUR
CHILDREN DESERVE BETTER. I AM
HERE BECAUSE I WILL ALWAYS BE
THAT PARENT. I AM HERE BECAUSE
DESPITE MY FAILURES I HAVE TO
FIND A WAY TO MAKE THIS RIGHT.
AND I NEED YOUR HELP TO DO SO
FOR DEREK AND EVERY OTHER
PERSON LIKE HIM. IN MY PERSONAL
OPINION. REGIONAL CENTER. WHILE
WELL MEANING IS FILLED WITH
PEOPLE WHO DO YOU TRULY CARE
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT DON'T GIVE A
ABOUT THEIR JOB. AND IT SHOWS.
AND THERE NEEDS TO BE
CONSISTENT SUPPORT THERE NEEDS
TO BE CONSISTENT TRAINING AND
THERE HAS TO BE CONSISTENT
FINDING. THAT A COMPLETE
OVERHAUL OF THE SYSTEM BECAUSE
IT IS BEYOND BEING ON LIFE
SUPPORT RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER.
HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY. MY NAME IS
ALEXIS ZERO. AND THE PROUD
PARENTS OF THREE ADULTS SCIENCE
ONE OF THEM THAT HAPPENS TO BE
ON THE SPECTRUM. I WORK FORTY
HOURS A WEEK PLUS OVERTIME AND
THE FOUNDER OF A NONPROFIT
CALLED FOUND IT I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
ALTERNATIVE MUSIC FOUNDATION.
AND A NEW BOARD MEMBER OF NORTH
BAY REGIONAL CENTER. LIKE MANY
MY SON DORIAN D. A. R. I. E. N.
DORIEN. IS THE REASON WE ARE
HERE TODAY. AT TWENTY SEVEN IS
NOW FINDING ITS WAY INTO THE
WORLD. ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT FOR
LACK OF TRYING. I'VE SAID FOR
THE LAST SIXTEEN YEARS THE
WORST THING I EVER DID AS A
MOTHER WAS TO MOVE MY FAMILY
FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY TO SOLANO
COUNTY. WHY BECAUSE AS SOON AS
YOU CROSS THE BRIDGE SERVICES
ARE DIMINISHED YOUR SUPPORT
GOES DOWN 50% RESOURCES ARE
DOWN 50% AND ALTHOUGH SOME
WOULD SAY THAT IT'S A GOOD
THING THAT ALL REGIONAL CENTERS
DO NOT RUN THE SAME WAY I
DISAGREE THE FOUNDATION OF ALL
REGIONAL CENTERS SHOULD BE
EXACTLY THE SAME AND IF ONE
CENTER HAS AN APPROVED VENDOR
THAT COMPRISED SERVICES THAT
WOULD BENEFIT OUR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS AND ALL CENTER SHOULD
ALLOW THAT WITH THAT VENDOR TO
BE APPROVED WITH LITTLE TO NO
ADDITIONAL STOPS. I HAVE NOT
SEEN THAT FROM MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE. ONCE WE MOVED FROM
ALAMEDA COUNTY TO SOLANO IT
TOOK A YEAR TO GET A
COORDINATOR ASSIGNED TO US.
ONCE A SIGN TO US OUR
COORDINATOR STAYED WITH US
THROUGH DORIAN'S JUNIOR YEAR AT
LEAST I THINK THAT WAS AT. I
CAN'T REMEMBER BECAUSE DORIAN'S
COORDINATOR WENT AND MY A AT
THAT TIME IN OUR LIVES. AND I
DID NOT KNOW THAT HE HAD
RETIRED FROM THE REGIONAL
CENTER UNTIL I SAW MATTER LOCAL
SAFEWAY. ABOUT SIX TO EIGHT
MONTHS AFTER THAT WE MET HIS
NEW COORDINATOR. WE MET WITH
HER ONE TIME ATTEMPTED TO DO A
FOLLOW UP. SHE WAS NO LONGER
RETURNING MY CALLS WHY BECAUSE
SHE WAS NO LONGER EMPLOYED WITH
THE REGIONAL CENTER. NEW
COORDINATOR NEW MEETING FOLLOW
UP WITHIN OUR AGREED UPON AND A
GREAT AMOUNT OF TIME OF THREE
MONTHS AND AGAIN NO COORDINATOR
TO BE FOUND I LEFT MESSAGES AND
AFTER AWHILE OF TRYING I CALLED
THE SUPERVISOR AND AT THAT TIME
I WAS TOLD BY THE SUPERVISOR IT
WAS NOT THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO
NOTIFY THE CLIENTS WHEN A
COORDINATOR HAS LEFT AND IT WAS
THE CLIENT THAT NEEDED TO CALL
THE REGIONAL CENTER. WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO DO. I CAN'T SAY. THIS
HAS CHANGED WITH THE MOST
RECENT COORDINATOR CHANGE FOR
DORIAN WE WERE GIVEN NOTICE BY
BOTH THE OUTGOING COORDINATOR
AND HIS NEW COORDINATOR.
UNFORTUNATELY THROUGH ALL OF
THE CHANGES THEY STILL CAN'T
SEE HIS NAME PROPERLY.
THROUGHOUT DORIAN'S. YEARS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SECURE
BEHAVIOR THERAPY FOR AND WHEN
IT WAS NEEDED HOWEVER THE OLDER
HE BECAME HIS NEEDS ALSO
CHANGED HE NEEDED MORE
SOCIALIZATION BECAUSE HE WASN'T
GETTING AT WE ASK FOR RESOURCES
AND WAS GIVEN AN OUTDATED
RESOURCE SHEET. WE FOUND OUT
THAT MOST OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WERE WERE
OUT THERE THAT WERE GIVEN TO US
FOR EITHER OUT OF BUSINESS OR
DIDN'T FIT. MY SON'S NEEDS
COORDINATOR AT THAT TIME THIS
WAS MORE THAN FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
HAD SUGGESTED ACCOUNT. I TRIED
TO ASK FOR MORE PRO AND MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
ACCORDING TO REALLY DIDN'T KNOW
TOO MUCH ABOUT IT BUT INSISTED
THAT IT WOULD BE A REALLY GOOD
THING FOR DURING TO ATTEND. IT
WASN'T. IN THREE SHORT DAYS
DINES BEHAVIOR REGRESSED. I
STARTED RECEIVING CALLS THAT
DURING AN WAS NOT LOOKING THE
BATHROOM DOORS AND THE FORCE
AND CRAWLING ON THE GROUND AND
TAKING HIS CLOTHES OFF AT
SCHOOL. ALTHOUGH THIS HAPPENED
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO I BRING IT UP
BECAUSE SOME THINGS HAVE NOT
CHANGED. I FEEL THE COORDINATOR
SHOULD BE SOMEWHAT FAMILIAR
WITH THE PROGRAMS THEY'RE
REFERRING CLIENTS TO. HANDING
SOMEONE A PIECE OF PAPER
DOESN'T ALWAYS HELP I GET IT I
UNDERSTAND IT'S ALSO THE
PARENTS RESPONSIBILITY TO DO
SOME OF THE RESEARCH AS WELL.
HOWEVER I BELIEVE THAT IF
SOMEONE AT THE CENTER HAD DONE
A SITE VISIT. AND MAKE NOTES IN
THE SYSTEM I BELIEVE THAT THEY
MAY HAVE KNOWN THAT MY SON WAS
NOT A FIT. FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THIS WILL ALSO GO ALONG WITH
WORK SITES AS WELL. DURING THIS
FINALLY MADE THE DECISION THAT
HE WOULD LIKE TO GO TO WORK SO
WE MADE ARRANGEMENTS FOR HIM TO
GET STARTED. A PROGRAM CALLED-GONE FOR GOOD. IT TOOK ABOUT
TWO MONTHS FOR US TO GET
STARTED. ALTHOUGH ANOTHER
CLIENT OF THE REGIONAL START
CENTER STARTED THEIR PROGRESS
AFTER US IT ONLY TOOK THEM
THREE WEEKS TO BEGAN WHEN IT
TOOK US MORE THAN TWO. WE WERE
TOLD THAT DORIAN WHICH SHOT OF
SOMEONE BEFORE HE STARTED. AND
WOULD HAVE TO AND I WOULD HAVE
TO STAY ON SITE AND STARRING
WAS NOT AN EMPLOYEE. THE
DOWNSIDE DURING TO NOT SHADOW
ANY WHEN YOU WATCH TELEVISION
FOR THREE HOURS. WELL HE WAS
WATCHING TV I WAS IN THE
LIBRARY. AND I WAS WATCHING
INDIVIDUAL SLEEP AT THE TABLE-
AND INDIVIDUALS WALKING THE
HALLWAY FOR ABOUT THREE HOURS.
ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL WAS ON THEIR
PHONE- WITH NO WHEN ENGAGING
ARE CHECKING ON THEM AND THIS
WENT ON FOR A FEW HOURS. DORIAN
CAME TO ME AND TOLD ME HE WAS
BORED WITH WATCHING TV. AND
THAT HE WANTED TO SHOT OF
SOMEONE. I ASKED THE WORKER AND
SHE SAID THERE WAS NO SUCH
THING AS SHADOWING. AND THAT
DURING COULD GOING TO THE ART
ROOM OR PLAY GAMES THAT'S NOT
WHAT HE WAS THERE FOR. ALTHOUGH
WE WERE HESITANT WHEN WE DID
MOVE FORWARD WITH GONE FOR
GOOD. DIANE WAS THERE TO WORK
AND IN THE- FIRST ONE AND A
HALF MONTHS THAT HE WAS THERE
HE ONLY WORKS FOR DAYS. MOST
DAYS HE WAS PICKED UP LATE AT
TIMES HE WASN'T PICKED UP AT
ALL I TOLD THIS TO HIS REGIONAL
CENTER COORDINATOR AND I TOLD
HER THAT I WANTED TO PLACE A
COMPLAINT. BUT IT WASN'T UNTIL
THREE MONTHS LATER WHEN WE HAD
TO SEE HER. DID SHE ACTUALLY
GIVE ME A FORM TO COMPLETE. IF
I NEEDED TO FILL OUT A FORM.
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN GIVEN TO
ME. THE DAY THAT I CALLED. AND
SAID THERE WERE ISSUES. WE TRY
TO FIND SOMETHING ELSE FOR
DURING AND IS VERY VOCAL AND
VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT WHAT HE
DOES NOT WANT TO DO. HE TOLD US
TO IS COORDINATOR NO JANITORIAL
NO LANDSCAPING NO SUB MINIMUM
WAGE. SHE SUGGESTED PRIDE I
REMINDED HER THAT HE DID NOT
WANT TO DO THE TYPES OF JOBS
THAT PRIDE OFFERED. SHE SAID
THEY HAD OTHER OPTIONS IN THE
COMMUNITY. SO AGAINST HER
BETTER JUDGMENT WE WENT AHEAD
AND WENT TO PRIDE. AND THE
FIRST THING THAT WE WERE TOLD
THAT DARIEN COULD DO. WITH
LANDSCAPING OR CONCERTS
CUSTODIAL WORK. DORIAN SAID
THAT HE WAS NOT INTERESTED IN
EITHER OF THOSE. THEY THEN
OFFERED TO WORK IN THE PRIDE
WHERE HOUSE MAKING THREE
DOLLARS AND TWENTY TWO CENTS AN
HOUR. HIS COORDINATOR DID NOT
LISTEN TO US. IN BOTH INSTANCES
WE COULD HAVE SAVE TIME AND
ENERGY IF SHE HAD LISTENED TO
SOMEONE FROM FROM US AND IF THE
REGIONAL CENTER HAD MADE
PERIODIC SITE VISITS TO THESE
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS. WE JUMP
OVER FOR DORIAN'S CONTINUE NEED
FOR SOCIALIZATION. I DRIVE MY
SON BETWEEN FREMONT ARANDA SAN
FRANCISCO SACRAMENTO DAVIS TO
FIND YOUR SUPPORT AND SOCIAL
GROUPS BECAUSE HIS COORDINATOR
HAS NO IDEA WHAT'S AVAILABLE.
THE LAST STRAW WAS WITH HIS A
RENDER GROUP WHICH COSTS NINETY
DOLLARS FOR AN HOUR AND TEN
MINUTES OF PEER SUPPORT. THEY
WENT ON BREAK THE ORGANIZER
CALLED AND SAID THAT THE GROUP
WAS GOING TO HANG OUT AT THE
FOOD TRUCKS HAD DINNER AND BE
WITH THEIR FRIENDS. WE THOUGHT
THAT WAS A GREAT IDEA AND TELL
THE ORGANIZER SAID THAT DORIAN
COULD PAY THE AID NINETY
DOLLARS. I THOUGHT THAT WAS
CREEK KIND OF CRAZY. THAT MY
SON WOULD PAY NINETY DOLLARS TO
HANG OUT WITH FRIENDS AT A FOOD
TRUCK. THIS ORGANIZATION IS NOT
VENDOR AS WITH REGIONAL CENTER.
SO THAT MONEY THAT DORIAN
SPENDS IS HIS OWN PERSONAL
MONEY AND IT'S HALF OF HIS
SOCIAL SECURITY INCOME. PRESS
THAT WAS THE LAST STRAW AND IT
WAS THAT MOMENT THAT DURING AND
I DECIDED TO START OUR OWN
GROUP CALLED FOUND IT WHERE WE
CAN PROVIDE PEER SUPPORT AND
SOCIALIZATION IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITY. OTHERS IS NOT A
PLAGUE BUT IT IS A VIABLE SORT
RESOURCE FOR GUYS AND GALS AND
IT DOESN'T COST ANY MONEY FOR
ANYONE TO ATTEND. WE'VE INVITED
DURING ITS COORDINATOR TO OUR
MEETINGS AND SHE'S NEVER
ATTENDED. YET ANOTHER CLIENTS
COORDINATOR HAS ATTENDED A
COMMUNITY MEETING. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHILE ONE WOULD DO
WITH THAT FOR THEIR CLIENT. OUR
COORDINATOR WOULDN'T DO IT FOR
HER CLIENT. BEING THAT HE'S THE
ONE THAT STARTED THIS
ORGANIZATION AND SOMETHING HE'S
VERY PROUD AT. THIS IS NOT TO
BE A DICK HONEST COORDINATOR
BUT MORE SO FOR THE LACK OF
COMMUNICATION RESOURCES BENDER
PROCESS AND A LACK OF OVERSIGHT
AND A LACK OF FUNDING. I DON'T
HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS HOWEVER I
SAW THERE WAS A PROBLEM FOR MY
SON AND I WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING SO WE STARTED A
NONPROFIT AND I APPLIED TO
BECOME A BOARD MEMBER AND NORTH
BAY REGIONAL CENTER. DURING THE
REGIONAL CENTER MEETINGS I CAN
SEE THE VISION I CAN SEE THE
DIRECTION. I CAN SEE MOVED. THE
MOVEMENT ON A LARGE SCALE. BUT
IT DOES NOT TRANSLATE TO MY SON
AS A CLIENT. I KNOW THIS IS
BEING WORKED ON. AND WE HAVE AN
EXCEPTIONAL LEADER AT NORTE
REGIONAL CENTER. BUT IT'S BEEN
A REALLY LONG ROAD FOR STARRING
IN AND I AND I KNOW THAT THE
ROAD IN FRONT OF US CONTINUES
TO BE ALL ALONG WHEN. WE BAKED
FOR MORE FUNDING EFFORTS MORE
RESOURCES MORE COMMUNITY
OUTREACH WITH NORTH BAY
REGIONAL CENTER OR ALL REGIONAL
CENTERS. WHICH NO ONE SHOULD
HAVE TO SUFFER BECAUSE OF WHERE
THEY LIVE AND WE SHOULD ALL GET
THE SAME BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
ENTITLED TO IT. THAT'S ALL I
HAVE TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU. ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE OF THE PANEL.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH OF WHAT
I DESCRIBE YOU AS IS MY MOM
AFFAIRS. WE NEED A LOT OF MOM
AFFAIRS. I'M GONNA BREAK FROM
THE AGENDA I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
AN END IN OUR AUDIENCE. OF THE
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS WONDER
WILLIAMS WAS WHO. IS A DEAR
FRIEND OF MINE THAT ALSO WAS AN
AVID APPARENT I DISLIKE HER TO
BE ABLE TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
OF HER LIFE EXPERIENCE OF GOING
FORWARD. AND THEN AFTER THAT
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER UP. PRO TEN. AS
OKAY MULLIN AND I'D LIKE TO
HAVE HIM SAY A FEW WORDS I A
THIS WILLIAMS. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU SO AND I TO DO THIS
APPLY EVERYONE THAT IN THIS
TODAY BECAUSE MEANS THEY CAN OF
THIS ISSUE IN THIS CONCERN FOR.
OUR CHILDREN AND I LIKE TO SAY
CHILDREN WITH ABILITIES BECAUSE
EVERY PERSON IN THIS WORLD HAVE
AN ABILITY TO PROVIDE THAT
THEY'RE GIVING THAT THE OFFER.
IN SEOUL I'M IS GOING TO SHARE
WITH YOU AS A MOTHER AS A
PARENT ADVOCATE. WHAT I'VE
EXPERIENCED NOW I'VE YOU SAY
THAT. MY EXPERIENCES MAYBE A
LITTLE BEEN EXCEPTIONAL BECAUSE
I BUILT MY OWN APPARENT-
RESOURCE GROUP AND SO I BECAME
APPARENT ADVOCATE FOR THEM BUT
IN THE BEGINNING STAGES I CAN
SAY IT WAS ROUGH. TRYING TO
NAVIGATE AND UNDERSTAND THE
SYSTEM HOW IT WORKS ALL THE
ACRONYMS AND WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
IEP MEETING OR IPP MEANING IT
CAN BE INTIMIDATING. BECAUSE
YOU DON'T KNOW. HOW TO NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEM. AND WHAT I'VE
SHARED WITH- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER IS THE NEED TO HELP THE
PARENT. ADVOCATE AND WORK
THROUGH THE SYSTEM HELPING IT
TO BE MORE STREAMLINED. BUT I'M
A MOTHER OF TWO SONS MICHAEL
AND DAVID DAVID- IS CONSIDERED
IDT. BUT MY SON WHO IS NO
LONGER HERE HE PASSED AWAY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. HE WAS THE P.
TO ME OF JOY. HE WAS A BLESSING
TO ME AND TO EVERYONE HE
INTERACTED WITH. DAVID HAD MANY
DESIRES THINGS THAT HE WANTED
TO OVERCOME AND ACCOMPLISH AND
ONE OF THOSE THINGS WERE. GOING
OFF TO COLLEGE AND FOR PARENTS
WHO HAVE CHILDREN WITH WITH
DIFFERENT ABILITIES. THAT COULD
BE A CHALLENGE SOMETIMES
DEPENDING ON THE LEVEL OF
SPECTRUM THAT THEY'RE ON WITH
AUTISM. ALTHOUGH MY SON WAS
HIGH FUNCTIONING HE STILL HAD
DIFFICULTY IS LOOKING AT YOU.
EXPRESS SEEN WHAT HE NEEDED TO
SHARE BECAUSE HIS SPOTS WERE
RECAPTURED IN HIS IN HIS MIND
IN IT HE ARTICULATED THAT TO ME
THAT WAS HIS DIFFICULTY. BUT I
HAD TO PERSONALLY. GOAL TOTAL
TELL WITH THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES TO FIND. A PROGRAM FOR
MY SON HIS TEACHER WILL CALL ME
AND SAY WANDA I NEED YOU TO GO
OUT THERE AND ADVOCATE BECAUSE
I CAN'T GET THESE OTHER
AGENCIES TO HELP ME. PROVIDE
THE SERVICES THAT WE NEED. AND
I CAN SAY THAT MY REGIONAL
CENTER. A CORD NADER WAS
EXCEPTIONAL BUT WHEN SHE
RETIRED. BECAUSE I KNEW WHAT TO
DO I CAN'T SAY EVERY PARENT
KNOWS WHAT TO DO I NEED TO CALL
MY RESOURCES AN AXE FOR
REFERRAL. WHO IS THE BASS
COORDINATOR THAT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO HELP ME. GET THE
SERVICES MY CHILD MEET. AND AS
YOU'VE HEARD. DOWN END OF DEALT
WITH COORDINATORS THAT WERE NOT
FORTHCOMING. AND IN REGARDS TO
THEIR WEBSITE ON THAT TOO I IS
AN ISSUE MY COORDINATOR HAD TO
FORWARD ME ALL THE DIFFERENT.
PROGRAMS THAT WERE AVAILABLE
AND- REGIONAL CENTER THAT MY
SON UTILIZE WITH NORTH BAY
WOULD MOST OF THOSE SERVICES
WERE IN NAPA. I HAPPEN TO HAVE
A WHEELCHAIR SELF SYBIL VAN MY
SON NOT ONLY WILL ADD ID BE HE
WAS PHYSICALLY DISABLED DUE
MUSCULAR DYSTROPHY. BUT I YOU
DON'T HAVE A VAN A YOU KNOW
HAVE THE CAPABILITIES TO GET TO
THESE PLACES YOUR CHILD IS
STOCK. WHAT ELSE SERVICES
WITHOUT THE CAPABILITY TO
ENJOY. QUALITY OF LIFE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE. MAKING SURE ALL OUR
CITIZENS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE QUALITY OF
LIFE. IN SEOUL. MY SON DAVID
NOT ONLY DID HE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
SOLANO COMMUNITY COLLEGE. HOLD
A CULTURE PROGRAM AND LET ME
SAY THIS HE WAS THE CATALYST
FOR THAT PARTICULAR PROGRAM AND
WHEN I MEAN TO THAT IS. THEY
ALREADY HAD A ADOPTED A
HORTICULTURE PROGRAM BUT THE
PROGRAM DID NOT PROVIDE
SERVICES OR HAVE THE CAPABILITY
TO ALSO DEAL WITH SOMEONE IN
WILL CHEER SO TODAY THE SCHOOL
HAVE MADE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
BUT- I HAD TO PUT MY SON OUT
THERE. TO LEAD THE WEIGHING SO
ANOTHERCHILD CAN HAVE. THE
SAME OPPORTUNITIES THAT MIGHT
FUNDED. BUT I'M NOT IN AT EVERY
REGIONAL CENTER LOCATION. AND
BECAUSE OF THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT HOW TO STREAMLINE THIS
SYSTEM WERE THEY ARE OFFERING
THIS IS SIMILAR SERVICES BASED
ON THEIR AREA. AND ALSO HELPING
TO EQUIP PERRANCE WITH THE
TOOLS NECESSARY TO ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF THEIR TRIAL
EFFECTIVELY. I WILL ALSO CALL
THE PARA FROM HAIL BUT I LET
THEM KNOW I'M THE PARENT FROM
HAVEN'T BECAUSE I'M HERE TO
ADVOCATE FOR MY CHILD AND
ALTHOUGH I KNOW WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH ALL THE OTHER
CHILDREN I'M HERE TODAY ABOUT
MY SON. AND WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO ABOUT MY CHILD. AND THEN I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN MATRIX MATRIX
ACTUALLY TRAINED ME AS A PARENT
BECAUSE I TOO FELT LOST IN THE
PROCESS AND BECAUSE OF THAT
TRAINING I WAS ABLE TO NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEM LET THEM KNOW IN THE
I EP AND IPP PROCESS THAT. THIS
IS A PARTNERSHIP. IT'S NOT
YOU'RE TELLING ME WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN IT'S WORKING TOGETHER
COLLECTIVELY. TO MAKE SURE THAT
MY CHILD IN ANY OTHER CHILD
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR GOOD
GREAT QUALITY OF LIFE IN SEOUL
I JUST CAME TO THE AID TO-
SHARE MY EXPERIENCE AS A PARENT
AS A PARENT ADVOCATE. AND AS A
COUNCIL WOMAN FIGHTING IN
ADVOCATING FOR THE NEEDS OF OUR
CHILDREN AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU TODAY FOR ALLOW ME TO
COME THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER AND ALL THE OTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HERE TODAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU FOR THAT. ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE OUR PANEL'S. THANK YOU FOR
SHOWING UP IN EVERY ISSUE THAT
ONE THANK YOU- AND IN ALL
FAIRNESS AND I ALSO WANTED TO
SHARE THAT FOR IS MANY PEOPLE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE SYSTEM
WE HAVE SEVERAL MEMBERS THAT
ARE ABSOLUTELY ADVOCATES. AND
ENJOY. WITH A CONSIDER- A
EXCELLENT SERVICES ALSO SO IT'S
NOT TRYING TO SHOW A BIAS ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER. IT'S JUST A
WEE AS ELECTIVES GENERALLY HERE
THE BAT. AND LESS LESSER OF THE
GOOD I WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE
HEAR THE GOOD AS AS A OF.
COMPOUND GOING FORWARD- MISTER
MILLER PREACHY SHOWING UP ONE
G. TO SEVEN CHANCE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS RECALL NEXT PANEL THANK
YOU MISTER AND VERY BRIEFLY-
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES UP.
I WANT TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE
TO THE CHAIR HI MISTER FRAZIER
FOR STEADFAST LEADERSHIP WITHIN
OUR CAUCUS YOU'RE PASSIONATE
LEADERSHIP ON- ID DE- ISSUES AS
EXEMPLIFIED BY THE WORK OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE AND- I LOOK
FOR TO LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE
SURVEY RESULTS I KNOW IT'S NOT
A- SCIENTIFIC- TEST. OF A
PARENT OPINIONS BUT THAT
FEEDBACK- IS CRUCIAL I WANT TO
THANK OUR PARENT. UP PANEL FOR
THEIR CONVERSE FOR THEIR
COMMENTS ABOUT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE ARE
REGIONAL CENTERS FACE BUT- IT'S
NOT THE TOPIC OF THE HEARING
TODAY BUT I JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE- OUR COMMITMENT. TO
THE FUNDING ISSUE. WE ARE IN
THE WINDOW. THE PRE RECESS WIND.
WHERE WE HAVE A GROWING. AND A
BUDGET SURPLUS IF WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO MAKE THE STRUCTURAL
KINDS OF BUDGET FUNDING
CHANGES- IN THIS WINDOW I FEAR-
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY IN THE FUTURE.
SO THERE IS AN URGENCY AROUND
THIS ISSUE IT'S AN URGENCY THAT
I KNOW THE CHAIR- SHARES- WITH
THE OTHER MEMBERS ON THIS PANEL
SO- IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
PROPER OVERSIGHT FUNDING
TRAINING ALL THOSE THINGS MUCH
OF THIS COMES DOWN TO A BUDGET
DECISION AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE RATE STUDY AND STRUCTURAL-
BUDGET ISSUES SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH ON THAT BUT
GRATEFUL FOR EVERYBODY-
ATTENDING TODAY AND- FOR YOUR-
I OPENING- INPUT. THANK YOU
PHONE. TO REMOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANEL WHICH IS OUR CELL
ADVOCATE AND- THESE ARE THE
THIS IS THE PART I LIKE THIS IS
THE PEOPLE. THAT ACTUALLY ARE
RECEIVING THE SERVICES AND CAN
TELL US. THEIR REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE SO WE'RE GONNA
INVITE ROSEANNA ROSIE RYAN.
JUSTIN STEINBERG. AND WESLEY
WEATHERSPOON. WITHERSPOON FROM
UP AND- WE'LL START OFF WITH SO.
PRESENT IT WHEN YOU GET A
CHANCE TO SIT DOWN YOU'LL BE UP
FIRST OKAY. AND JUST SO ALL
THREE OF YOU KNOW YOU'RE MY
REAL HEROES. OKAY TERRORISM
WHEN YOU'RE READY I'M READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON. JOURNAL FRASER
I MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY. MY NAME IS
ROSY RYAN I'M A SELF ADVOCATE.
IN A MEMBER OF THE STATE
COUNCIL ON THE ABOUT
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES I
REPRESENT THE NINE STATE REGION.
I LOVE THE ART I REPRESENT
HOWEVER WE HAVE THE ISSUES TO
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TOP
TO TRAVEL. TO ANOTHER COUNTY
ARE MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR MILES. TO RECEIVE
SERVICES THEY DESERVE I'M A
CLIENT OF THE FAR NORTHERN
REGIONAL CENTER. I THINK MY
REGIONALS AND I'VE BEEN GOOD
ABOUT SUPPORTING SELF ADVOCATES
THEY SUPPORT PEOPLE FIRST IN MY%
AREA AND HELP. MAYBE BECAUSE-
BECOME A LEADER THE REGIONAL
CENTER ALSO HELPS ME PAY BILL
BY BEING MY REP PETE THIS IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME. I
CURRENTLY LIVE N AN APARTMENT
WITH A ROOMMATE IN REDDING. I
RECIEVED SUPPORTED LIVING
SERVICES I HAVE GOOD HELP
THROUGH PROPER SERVICE TO FIND
A PLACE TO LAY OF. I FRANKLY
DON'T HAVE HELP ON WEEKENDS I
NEED HELP ON WEEKENDS TOO. THE
STAFF WHO HELPED ME. CHANGES A
LOT WE NEED TO PAY PEOPLE
BETTER SO THEY CAN HELP WHEN I
NEED HELP. I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN APARTMENTS
THAT ARE AND NOT IN SAY PLACES.
WE NEED HELP. WE NEED TO HELP
PEOPLE WITH RANT SO THEY CAN
AFFORD TO LIVE IN SAFE PLACES
SALLY PEOPLE WILL TAKE A BAG TO
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. I USE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION TO GET
AROUND BUT LIVE IN A RURAL AREA.
SO THERE ARE ARE A LOT OF. SO
THERE ARE NOT A LOT OF OPTIONS
SOMETIMES I DON'T FEEL SAFE I
HAVE TO WAIT A LONG TIME
SOMETIMES. THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE
TO ME. ONE PROGRAM OREGANO
SHASTA CONNECT THAT OFFERS FREE
SERVICES. OUR FREE RIDES ON
SUNDAY TO ATTEND CHURCH OR TO
GO TO OTHER PLACES I WOULD LIKE
YOU SHOULD HAVE THIS PROGRAM.
SOME OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
EVERY. HERE WERE WEAPONS THAT
RURAL AREAS IN THE STATE I LIVE
IN A RURAL AREA. ONE OF THE
PROBLEM PROMISES I HAVE SEEN IS
THAT WHEN WE UP. PUBLIC. SAFETY
POWERS SHOT OFF SOME OF THE
WORLD DO NOT I WATER. WE SHOULD
SOLVE PROBLEMS LIKE THIS ONE.
THAT WITH THE MADE THIS THE
LIVE IN OR IS. I DON'T IN
REDDING. AND I THAT THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE THAT LIVE RATHER
FROM REGIONAL CENTERS IN THE
BIG ROLE A ARE AT I REPRESENT.
I AM RETIRED FROM WORKING I
WORK AS A PEER INSTRUCTOR AT
THE WE CARE A LOT ABOUT NATION.
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND. TEN TO
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. LET ME
TELL YOU ABOUT A JOB THAT I
QUIT. THE EMPLOYER WAS DOING
TIME STUDIES ON ME AND TESTED
JUST OF MY- READY. THEY WANTED
TO PAY ME LESS THAN MEN WAGE I
DIDN'T WANT TO BE COMPARED TO
SOMEONE ELSE AND I DESERVED A
BETTER WORKPLACE SO I WALKED
OUT. I THINK EVERY PERSON
SHOULD GET PAID THE SAME WORK.
THE SAME FOR WORK THEY DO. A
LOT OF TIMES I DO NOT FEEL SAFE
WE NEED TO CREATE MORE SAFE
PLACES FOR SLUSH BY ACTION.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE JOB. I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE YOU THE SOCIAL
RECREATION PROGRAMS COME BACK
TO THE REGIONAL CENTER. SOME
PEOPLE DISABILITIES HAVE A SAFE
PLACE. THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
FUN ONE OF MY FAVORITE PROGRAMS
WHERE THE DANCES THE DANCERS
ARE GOOD. IT GIVES ME A CHANCE
TO CATCH UP WITH PEOPLE AND
SOMEONE WILL COME UP TO ME AND
SAY HI. I WANT TO FEEL SAFE I
WANT OPPORTUNITIES TO HAVE MORE
FRIENDS. I WANT THAT SUPPORTS I
NEED I THINK THE STATE
LEGISLATORS SHOULD HELP THE
REGIONAL CENTERS IN OTHER
PROGRAMS. DO YOU HAVE THE
FUNDING TO BE SURE THAT WE CAN
LIVE. THE ALLIES WE WANT. SO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
JUSTIN. JUSTIN'S FROM YOU READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AS ONLY ONE
FRAZIER AND EVERYONE I AM
EXTREMELY HONORED TO BE HERE
I'M IN A UNIQUE POSITION HERE
BECAUSE I'M NOT ACTUALLY A
MEMBER OF A REGIONAL CENTER-
PART AVERAGE JUST BECAUSE I
THINK AT THE TIME WHEN I WAS
SAME PUBLIC SCHOOL WE DIDN'T
REALLY KNOW. THAT THESE THINGS
EXISTED SO I DEFINITELY THINK.
AWARENESS ON THESE REGIONAL
CENTERS IS DEFINITELY KEY.
BEFORE I GO ANY FURTHER I AM AN
AMBASSADOR FOR SPECIAL OLYMPICS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHICH I
HAVE BEEN A PART OF THAT
ORGANIZATION FOR SIXTEEN YEARS.
AT AND I LOVE GOING AROUND
GIVING SPEECHES. SO I ALSO WANT
TO JUST GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND. SO WHEN I WAS FIRST
DIAGNOSED MY DISABILITIES THE
PERSON DOING SO. GOT THIS IT
REACHES EARNERS CONCLUSION THAT
I HAD A SEVERE INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY AND THEY THOUGHT I
WOULD BE ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL.
I PROVED THEM WRONG NOT ONLY
DID I GRADUATE FROM GUN HIGH
SCHOOL INTO THE LITTLE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WITH. A SKILL OF
FROM ZERO TO FOUR ONE ON MY GP
WAS LIKE A THREE POINT EIGHT.
BY I THEN WENT ON AND GOT MY
MASTER'S DEGREE SO. YEAH I.
MISDIAGNOSIS LIKE THAT THEY'RE
JUST GOING TO CAUSE STRESS. SO
ANYWAY. I'VE HEARD GOOD THINGS
ABOUT WHAT THE REGIONAL CENTERS
DO BUT ALSO WHERE THEY NEED TO
BE IMPROVED. AND WHEN I WAS
DOING COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND MY
UNDERGRADUATE WORK AT SAN
TRANSFERRED I DID WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF VOCATIONAL REHAB.
WHICH PROVIDED SOME SIMILAR
SERVICES LIKE JOB COACHING AND
PAYING FOR COLLEGE. THE FIRST
TIME AFTER I GRADUATED I HAD A
COUNSELOR THAT FOCUSED. ON ME
TRYING TO GET A JOB. BUT I WAS
ADAMANT ABOUT GOING TO COLLEGE
SO THAT ENDED UP. NOT WORKING
OUT. WHICH MADE ME FEEL LIKE IT
WAS A THEY WERE APPROACHING MY
ISSUE. OR MY CASE WITH A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH YOU KNOW
WHAT THAT DOESN'T WORK. YOU
NEED TO BE ABLE TO TAILOR YOUR
SERVICES TO FIT THE NEEDS OF
THOSE CLIENTS. AND I REALLY
THINK THE SAME COULD BE SAID
FOR. REGIONAL CENTERS TO. I HAD
BETTER LUCK WHEN I TRANSFERRED
TO SAN FRANCISCO STATE WITH
ANOTHER COUNSELOR WHO. HELP ME.
PAY FOR MY BOOKS AND THE
TUITION. FOR MY HISTORY
UNDERGRADUATE MAJOR A BUT WHEN
IT CAME TO TIME TO GOING TO
GRADUATE SCHOOL WHERE I
COMPLETED MY MASTERS IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION. I HAD A PRIVATE
SCHOLARSHIPS THAT THE PARTNER
VOCATIONAL REHAB WAS NOT GOING
TO PAY. FOR THAT. SO GIVE ME
FOR MAY I SHOULD'VE MORE
RESEARCH BEFORE I DECIDED TO GO
THAT ROUTE BUT STILL IT
WOULD'VE BEEN NICE TO HAVE THAT
KIND OF SUPPORT. SO NOW I'M
CURRENTLY UNEMPLOYED BY I'M
LOOKING AT EVENTUALLY GETTING
IN TOUCH WITH A REGIONAL CENTER
BUT MY PASSION IS STILL BEING
AN ADVOCATE FOR THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY. WHICH IS WHY I'M
GRATEFUL THAT PEOPLE LIKE YOU
ARE HERE AS CHAMPIONS OF THIS
MOVEMENT. WE REALLY NEED AS
MANY ALLIES AS WE CAN GET. SO
MY PASSION AGAIN I WANT TO. YOU
KNOW GET BACK TO THE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY BE AN ADVOCATE IN
SOME FORM OR ANOTHER. AND I
KNOW MAYBE GETTING IN TOUCH
WITH A REGIONAL CENTER LIKE.
THE SAN ANDREAS REGIONAL CENTER
BECAUSE I LIVE IN PAUL TELL TO
GETTING IN TOUCH WITH THE MIGHT
MAYBE HELP ME FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO GO ABOUT. DOING SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. SO THAT'S BASICALLY
ALL I HAVE TO SAY AND AGAIN MY
MESSAGES. WHEN IT COMES TO
SERVICES. THE THEY NEED TO BE
TAILORED FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
REALLY BIG AMBITIONS LIKE GOING
ON A COLLEGE A GOING TO GRAD
SCHOOL LIKE ME YOU CAN'T HAVE
THIS ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
AND I ALSO COULD ARGUE THAT
ALSO APPLIES TO US SPECIAL
EDUCATION IN THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AS WELL SO THAT'S WHAT I'VE
LEARNED OVER THE COURSE OF MY
THIRTY YEARS OF LIFE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. VERY GOOD WESLEY.
GOOD AVENUE CHURCH I'M AFRAID
YOU'RE A MEMBER COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY MY NAME IS
WESLEY WAS GOING I'M A SELF
ADVOCATE IN THAT LARGE MEMBER
OF THE STATE CAN ALSO DEVELOP
DISABILITIES I AM ALSO CHAIR OF
THE PLAN THE FIRST COMMITTEE.
WHEN I WAS AT LARGE MEMBER OF
THE COUNCIL I LIVE IN LOS
SANDERS WITH MY PARENTS I'VE
BEEN MARRIED FOR SEVEN YEARS.
MY WIFE AND I HAPPY LIVE
TOGETHER FOR THE FIRST THREE
YEARS. WE HAVE- APARTMENT BUT
THE HOUSING PRICES GOT TOO HIGH
IN THE AIR WITH LIMóN AND WAS
VERY UNSAFE. BECAUSE A HIGH
PRICE IN STATE ISSUES I HAD THE
MOVE BACK TO MY PARENTS HOUSE
AND MY WIFE MOVED BACK TO HER
PARENTS HOUSE. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX HAVE BEEN PLOY
PART TIME FOR TWENTY HOURS A
WEEK AS A PRIVATE CORNER AT
YOUR HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES. WORK
PROVIDES ME WITH A SENSE OF
BELONGING AND FRIENDS. WORK
TAUGHT ME TO UNDERSTAND
DIFFERENT THINGS. WHAT WHAT
WEST ARE WORKING AT YOUR
HOSPITAL I HAD A FRIEND. I HAD
A FRIEND SHE HELLO BUT LGBTQ
COMMUNITY BY HAVE THE FOR A
FRIEND AT AT AT THE JOB. SO I
AYE KURT PEOPLE GIVE OUT OF
WORK BECAUSE YOU LEARN ABOUT
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
PEOPLE WHICH IS WHICH IS REALLY
GOOD IS GOOD FOR DIVERSITY IN
CALIFORNIA. I USE A COMBINATION
OF PARA TRANSIT RIGHT HERE AND
BUS TO GET TO WORK IT OUT THE
COMMUNITY. CELL WITH MY JOB I
WORKED. WILL THE IT HAVE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT BILL THIS AND THE
COMMUNITY WHAT WOULD WHAT WOULD
BE A BIG GREAT THE COMMITTEE
THAT TO UTILIZE THE PEOPLE
DISABILITIES ABILITIES THEY
HAVE LIABILITIES. I AM A CLIENT
OF THE REDUCE OUR WEBSITE. I
GET HELP WITH SELF ALSEA
TRAININGS AS SOCIAL RECORD ACT
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS BUSY MUSEUMS
AND- THE KOREANS THERE ALLOWED
TO. PROGRAMS REGISTER MY WHY
WENT TO TOGETHER SO WE COULD
USE THESE GREAT SERVICES. PRO I
AM 1263% HER DOWN THE PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN WITH THEIR AGING
CARE GIVERS SOUL AND FORGE
UNFORTUNATELY. PARENTS ARE
GONNA GET OLDER IN OLD THAN YOU
THE CANAL AND I'M FOR HAD TO
SAY THIS BUT IF YOU'RE GONNA
PAY AWAY. I WANT TO LIVE MY
WIFE BUT IS IT'S BEEN AND LOS
ANGELES. MY WIFE LIKE BY A
PLACE WE CAN AFFORD THAT IS
SAFE. NOTE NEW YEAR'S OR NEED
AND SAFE NEIGHBORHOODS ARE
AFFORDABLE NINETY HELP WITH
RENT. PAYMENTS SO. I WENT TO MY
SPIRITS A SPEC EDUCATION. I
HAVE ONE CLASS MAY I WITH A
SCHOOL WITH UNFORTUNATELY HE
ADDED CAN PROBLEMS IN THE DIED.
I HAD NO THEIR PURSE I WOULD
SUSPECTED CASE YOU WITH. HE'S
HE'S HOMELESS. WHAT WE NEED TO
HELP OUT THE HOMELESS BECAUSE A
LOT OF PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
ALSO MAY HAVE PROBLEMS HAVE HOW
THE HOUSE. I AM ALSO 1260%
REDUCE THEIR CONSUMERS WHO ARE
WORKING AND COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED PLUMMET. BUT EVEN
THOUGH I HAD I HAD A HARD TIME
FIND WORKING GET OFFERS EVEN
THOUGH I WANT TO GO TO SCHOOL
SO LIKE I GOT MY BACHELOR'S
DEGREE AND WITH A REALLY GOOD
SCHOOL. AND HOW HARD TO GET A
JOB OFFER TOOK ME LIKE ELEVEN
MONTHS TO GET A JOB OFFER. IT
WAS IT WAS A GOOD ECONOMY SO I
LIKE MORE HELP FOR PEOPLE
DISABILITIES. WHO GRADUATE
ACOSTA FIND JOBS AND I KNOW
PEOPLE WITH ADVANCED DEGREES
HAVE A HARD TIME FINDING WORK
TOO SO. AT LIKE I LIKE TO THE
COULD TO HELP HELP PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO WHO GO TO BASS
AGREES HAVE BASS AGREES TO THE
FIGHT BY APPOINTMENT TO WEAR
BUT WHAT THEY PURSUE. THIS IS
THE UNSTOPPABLE TO ME. IN
ADDITION PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES A SUBJECT TO
SOCIAL ISOLATION. I HAD A HARD
TIME TO FIND A PARTNER SO A LOT
OF PEOPLE DISABILITIES THEY
WANT TO HAVE SO IT'S GOING TO
GO WITH OR FRIENDS AND THEY
HAVE DIFFICULT TO FIND HER
FRIENDS IN RELATIONSHIPS. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE I WANT
ADDRESS. MY WIFE. MY WIFE MAKE
LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE AND HE
CAN'T AFFORD TO GO OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY LIKE TO SEE A MOVIE I
WANTED TO BE A PART OF THE
COMMUNITY HE VERY BAD I WANT TO
GET OUT FOR DAY PROGRAM ALSO A
LOT OF MY FRIENDS I WENT TO
SCHOOL WITH GO DAY PROGRAM TO
MAKE LESS THAN WAGE SO SOME
PEOPLE I WENT TO COLLEGE WITH
DURING DAY PROGRAMS MAKE IN.
SELMA WAGE. THE POINT A FIRST
COMMITTEE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. SHOULD GIVE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND CAREER BASS MID
FOR STAFF WHO SUPPORT. PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES. TO GET JOBS
A COMPETITIVE IN THE GRAY
APPOINTMENT. ALSO RECOMMENDED
THAT THE STATE SHOULD PROVIDE
SUPPORTS PROVIDERS LOOK INTO
TRANSITION FOR SHELTER
WORKSHOPS TO COMPETITIVE IN THE
GREAT EMPLOYMENT. LASTLY
DEPARTED FIRST COMMITTEE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD PASS LEGISLATION TO
CREATE INCENTIVES FOR EMPLOYERS
WHO SHOW A COMMITMENT TO
COMPETITIVE IN THE GRADE POINT
IT BY USING TRANSPORTATION
SOLUTIONS INTO THEIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES SO A LOT OF PEOPLE
DISABILITIES HAVE PROBLEMS WITH
TRANSPORTATION AND I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT. WE WORK THE
BUSINESSES FIND SOME GOOD
TRANSPORTATION FOR THEM. THIS
LAST RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
TYPICALLY IMPORT TO ME I THINK
YOU HAVE TO WAIT LONG. NOW TIME
I DO NOT FEEL SAFE ON THE BUS
TRYING TO GO TO WORK A HOMES
FOR WORK. I ALSO HAVEFRIENDS
WHO USE WHEELCHAIRS HAD TO WAIT
EVEN LONGER TO TAKE THE BUS.
RIGHT HERE ARE PARATRANSIT SO
AS AS A BIG PROBLEM PEOPLE
DISABILITIES. WE HAD TO GO
IMPAIR TRANSIT WILL GET THE
TIMES WE WANTED IN. ACT I COULD
GO ON FOR LONG TIME SO CAN GET
NOW. AND WITH THE BY THIS. BUT
SIR VERY SPOT SOMEPLACE DON'T
HAVE BUT I PART OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE ME BUT SERVICE. IN THE
CITY'S IS THIS BY SOME PLACE.
SOME HAVE LOTS SERVICE OF A HOW
ABOUT ANY HARD AT SO. I FORTY
PEOPLE DO LAW OF THIS BILL IS
NOT FEEL IN DO NOT HAVE OUR
TOPIC TO MAKE FOR. WORK HELPED
ME BUT I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
TO FEEL SO IT NOT HAVE FRIENDS.
WE NEED DO A BETTER JOB FOR BY
OPPORTUNE. TO BE IN THE LIKELY
YOU TO REGISTER PO. SO I'M WENT
ON WITH A LAKE FOR PEOPLE THAT
UP NOW. THAT THEY COULD FIND
JOB THEY CAN GET MARRIED AND BE
PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS IN THE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE PANEL OF
THE OF KAMALA OR ANY COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. WANT TO THANK EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU- AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR DEGREES.
AND YOU ARE A SPECIAL LADY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IN ONE.
SERVICES FORMAL SO FOR THE
RECORD MOHAMMED HAD TO FEND ON
TO WORK WITH LAST COUPLE YEARS
IN. I CAN'T SAY YOU ENOUGH FOR.
JUST YOUR ADVOCACY FOR THE FOR
THE FOR THE AND ALL YOUR WILL
TO PARTICIPATE WITH ME. YOU
DON'T IN THIS LEVEL OF JUST.
ENCOURAGING ME AND ALSO SHARING
WITH ME HOW I CAN BE A BETTER
ADVOCATE IN YOUR YOU KNOW IN A
ROLE THAT. YOU'RE A GOOD MENTOR
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OFFER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THE FLOOR IS ALL YOURS I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- FIRST I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATIONS ON HOW WE- ARE
WORKING WITH OUR COMMUNITY- AND
VALUING THEIR INPUT. AND BEING
ABLE TO GIVE US GUIDANCE AND
INPUT INTO IMPROVING THE SYSTEM
TO DELIVER SERVICES FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE- BUT
I ALSO WANT TO- ACKNOWLEDGE
JUST THE REMARKABLE PANELS THAT
YOU JUST HAD- BUT SAY GOSH YOU
KNOW HAVING TO FOLLOW THAT
REALLY- OKAY I WILL DO MY BEST.
BUT THEY ARE JUST ABSOLUTELY
REMARKABLE AND SO I DO FEEL
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO BE A PART
OF THAT DISCUSSION TODAY WAS
SUCH A REMARKABLE FOLKS THAT
JOIN TO- WHEN. I'M WE WERE HERE
LAST IN. I WAS ASKED BY THE
COMMITTEE TO PRESENT ON WHAT
OUR SYSTEM SERVICES ARE AND HOW
WE DELIVER SERVICES. AND DURING
THAT TIME I WAS ALSO ABLE TO
PROVIDE. THAN JUST A OF
FRAMEWORK FOR WHERE WE HAD
PRIORITIES AND INITIATIVES AND
I'D LIKE TO JUST GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE. ON SOME OF THOSE
EFFORTS- WHILE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S CONTINUE TO WORK
TO BE DONE WITH OUR COMMUNITY
AND MANY OF THE INITIATIVES
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON. ARE
NOT JUST AS I OFTEN SAY IT'S
NOT JUST AN EVENT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT. HOW DO WE MOVE OUR
SERVICE SYSTEM FORWARD BECAUSE
OUR OUR NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS ARE CHANGING AND WE
ALSO LEARN AND IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES TO BE ABLE TO DO
THINGS DIFFERENTLY. SO QUICKLY
JUST AS AN UPDATE ON ONE ALSO
PROVIDE JUST A FRAMEWORK FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE
SERVING- ABOUT- TEN YEARS AGO
WHEN WE WERE TAKING A LOOK AT-
TRACKING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE ONE
OF THE AREAS IN WHICH WE
RECOGNIZE AND SEEING INCREASED
NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
AUTISM- WE WERE SERVING ABOUT
FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM. AT THE
TIME THAT REPRESENT A 20% OF
THE CONSUMER POPULATION THAT WE
SERVE. I'M TODAY WE'RE SERVING
ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO HAVE AUTISM.
35% OF THEM WHICH IS
REPRESENTING OF OUR TOTAL
CONSUMER POPULATION- OF NOTE
AND THIS IS I THINK JUST REALLY
WHERE THE RELEVANCE IS TWENTY.
OF THOSE- INDIVIDUALS WITH-
AUTISM UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
TWO IT RUPTURES 80% OF OUR-
AUTISM POPULATION. AND SO AS
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT HOW WE
MOVE OUR SYSTEM FORWARD AND HOW
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT SERVICES
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT OUR
SYSTEM CHANGES. NOT ONLY THAT
BUT ALSO BASED ON OUR
ETHNICITIES. TODAY WE'RE
PROJECTING- SERVICES IN. OUR
CURRENT YEAR IN JANUARY OF.
SUPPORTING THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS FOR
PROTECTING THIS NEXT YEAR- IT
WHICH IS IDENTIFIED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET. OF
SUPPORTING. THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
EIGHT THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO AND OF ENJOY. WE ARE
ALSO RIGHT. THE NEED TO MAY
SURE THAT WE- WERE ESTABLISHING
ONLY SERVICES. YEAH BUT
RECOGNIZE THE AND- OF THAT
ACCOUNT OF. OVER INTO. AND I
THINK SOME OF THE UPDATES I
GIVE YOU TODAY WILL WE'LL GET
TO THAT- WE JUST RECENTLY-
MOVED. REALLY EVERYBODY FROM
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS. IN
MAY OF TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE
WERE SERVING A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS AND STATE OPERATED
SERVICES. BUT AGAIN THIS IS A
REAL FRAMEWORK TO SAY THAT WE
ARE REALLY A COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM- AS OF
TODAY WE REALLY WE ONLY HAVE
ONE INDIVIDUAL REMAINING AT THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER THAT WILL
BE MOVING TO THE COMMUNITY. SO
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED NOT ONLY
DEVELOPING RESOURCES FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. BUT REALLY THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE SIMILAR
NEEDS- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH IS
THE IMPLEMENTATION AND APPROVAL
OF THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM. SO IN JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE HAD
APPROVAL FEDERAL APPROVAL TO
IMPLEMENT TODAY WE HAVE A
HUNDRED TWELVE INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE THEIR INDIVIDUAL BUDGETS.
IN PROVIDING THEIR OWN SELF
DIRECTED CHOICE- AND
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR SERVICES-
WE DO HAVE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN
SELECTED TO PARTICIPATE. IN THE
NATIONAL STAGES AND WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
ORIENTATIONS. AND MEETINGS TO
BE ABLE TO HELP THEM. ACHIEVE
THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL BUDGETS TO
MOVE FORWARD. WE ALSO RELIGIOUS
THE- AS YOUR FROM YOUR WITH
WITH THE RATE STUDY AND MARCH
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND
THE UPDATED ONE IN JANUARY-
THIS YEAR- WITH THE UPDATED
RATE MODELS- THAT WAS THROUGH A
COLLABORATIVE WORK WITH. I'M
NOT ONLY THE COMMUNITY BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAD IT PUT
FROM THE COMMUNITY. NOT FOR
SERVICE. THROUGH SURVEY BUT
THAT MEETING WITH OUR CAN. THE
CONSUMER SELF ADVOCATES AND
FOUND MEMBERS. THIS IS REALLY
AND NOT ONLY INFORM THE RIGHTS
TO BUT ALL. TO A- WHERE DO WE
NEED TO TAKE A. LOOK AT TO HAVE
FOR CONVERSATIONS AS TO WHAT'S
IN. TO END OF. AND IS WERE
STRUCTURE OUR SERVER. AND
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW MOVE AND-
FOR. IN ARE SAYS FOR WERE. THAT
WE NEED TO KEEP THAT IN. IN THE
FOR OF OUR MIND. ONE OF THE
AREAS IN WHICH I HAD TALKED
ABOUT THE LAST TIME WAS
IMPORTANCE OF TAKING A LOOK OUR
A- OUR NEEDS AND SERVICES TO AN
BEING DELIVERED. IT DOES THOSE
INTO THE COMMUNITY ONE WAS
WITHIN OUR- NOW. SO WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO REALLY ENHANCE OUR
SAFETY NOT SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH COMPLEX NEEDS
AS WE CONTINUE TO SEE THE NEEDS
OF INDIVIDUALS CHANGING. THE
COMPLEXITY OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
CO OCCURRING NEEDS PARTICULARLY
THOSEWHO ARE IN FOSTER CARE
AND BEING ABLE TO MEET THOSE
NEEDS IS REALLY IMPORTANT. I
HEARD A COUPLE THE PANEL
MEMBERS TALK ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES OF NAVIGATING
SYSTEMS NOT ONLY THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM BUT THEN ALSO
OTHER SYSTEMS AND IT'S A IT'S
NOT AN EASY WAY TO NAVIGATE. SO
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE DID
THAT IS IDENTIFYING WAYS THAT
WE CAN SUPPORT- THE REGIONAL
CENTERS IN ACCESSING SERVICES
THROUGH CASE COORDINATION- WE
WERE ABLE TO- HAVE PART OF THE
BUDGET ACT LAST YEAR OF
REDUCING SERVICE CASELOAD
RATIOS ONE TO TWENTY FIVE. FOR
THOSE COMPLEX NEEDS SO WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING
THAT THIS YEAR WE HAVE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET. IS
A REDUCE CASELOAD RATIO FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE AGES THREE
AND FOUR YEARS OLD TO ONE TO
FORTY FIVE AND THIS REALLY DID
STEM FROM A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD WITH
FAMILIES- AND ALSO SERVICE
COORDINATORS TO SAY THAT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT'S CHALLENGING
IS THAT WHEN YOU HAVE. A YOUNG
FAMILY WHO'S JUST BEEN-
INFORMED THAT THEY HAVE A CHILD
WITH A DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
AND THE CHALLENGE OF NAVIGATING
WHETHER SCHOOL SYSTEM ACCESS
SEEN COORDINATED CARE THROUGH
OTHER SYSTEMS AND THEN ALSO
NAVIGATING THE REGIONAL CENTER.
THAT HAVING THAT LOWER CASE
LOAD RATIO IS REALLY IMPORTANT
SO WE HAVE THAT PROPOSED THIS
YEAR IN MOVING THAT FORWARD.
ALSO WITH THE SAFETY NET IS
RECOGNIZING THAT FAMILIES HAVE
SAID TO US THAT THEY REALLY
NEED THE SUPPORTS IN A
PREVENTATIVE WAY TO SUPPORT
THEM IN THE FAMILY HOME AS
OPPOSED TO. NOT ONLY
STABILIZING IN INDIVIDUAL WHEN
THINGS HAVE REALLY BECOME TOO
AND A CUTE CRISIS SO WE'VE
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ADDITIONAL SERVICES TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE. A CRISIS TEAM
THAT CAN BE SUPPORTED IN THE
FAMILY HOME OR IN THE SETTING
THAT. THEIR LIVES. AND BEATING
TO MEDI. IN RISK OF HAVING THEM
MOVE. TO A RISK. SETTING THAT
IS REALLY NOT TO BE INCLUSIVE
IN THE THOU HOME. WELL IT'S NOT
AS IS PRETTY AS SOME OF THE
OTHER INITIATIVES YOU KNOW IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AS A
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES.
BECAUSE WE ARE DEPENDENT AS A
SYSTEM WE HAVE A VERY.
WONDERFUL BENEFIT OF AN
ENTITLEMENT AND CALIFORNIA FOR
THE LETTERMAN OUT WE'RE WE'RE
REALLY TIED TO OUR FEDERAL
MATCH AND SO COMPLIANCE WITH
OUR AGE CBS FEDERAL RULE WE'VE
HAD SOME I'M REALLY GREAT
PROGRESS IN BEING ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT. THE PROVIDER SELF
ASSESSMENTS WORKING WITH THEIR
PROVIDERS WESLEY DID A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF TALKING ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT AND HOW
WE MOVE THAT FORWARD. SOME OF
THE FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WE HAVE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
TO HELP PROVIDERS MOVE TOWARDS
COMPLIANCE HAS REALLY BEEN
TARGETED TO THE- SUPPORT OF
COMPETITIVE AND INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT AS AN EXAMPLE.
ANOTHER AREA IN WHICH WE WERE
ABLE TO MAKE SOME PROGRESS AS
WE CLOSE THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS WE'RE ABLE TO PRESERVE-
THE COMMUNITY PLACEMENT PLAN
START UP DOLLARS TO START
DEVELOPING OTHER RESOURCES IN
THE COMMUNITY. THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE WE HAVE TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE EVERY
YEAR TO DEVELOP THE COMMUNITY.
WANT TO JUST GIVE YOU A COUPLE
OF EXAMPLES OF WHERE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO USE THAT MORE TOWARDS
KIND OF THAT COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AS OPPOSED TO
DEVELOPING- HOMES FOR FOLKS
MOVING FROM THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER. ONE AGAIN YOU KNOW IS A
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT WE WERE ABLE TO FIND
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE NEW
EMPLOYMENT RELATED ACTIVITIES
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY RESOURCE
DEVELOPMENT FUND WE'RE ALSO
ABLE TO REALLY PUSH FORWARD THE
INITIATIVES TO HOUSING AND
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW WE CAN-
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
INDIVIDUALS. IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
SUPPORT THROUGH OUR COMMUNITY
RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT FUND TEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
ELEVEN MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROJECTS WHICH YIELDED A
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT SET ASIDE
UNITS FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENT THIS DISABILITIES-
WE'VE WE ARE ALSO REALLY
FOCUSED ON HOW DO WE ENHANCE
OUR RISK MANAGEMENT. AND
REGIONAL CENTER AND SERVICE
SYSTEM. ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVER.
COUPLE THINGS THAT REALLY CAME
FOR TO OUR OUR TO. WAS HOW DO
WE MAKE AND AGAIN YOU YOU HEARD
IT TODAY. IS THAT WHEN A MEMBER
IS ACCESSING SERVICES IN ONE
AREA VERSUS ANOTHER AREA HOW DO
WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE GETTING
THE SAME INFORMATION FROM ONE
REGIONAL CENTER TO THE NEXT. SO
ONE OF THE LAST YEAR'S
INITIATIVES THAT WE HAD FORWARD
THAT WERE IN THE FINAL STAGES
OF. OF TALKING TO- APPLICANTS
WAS THIS INFORMATION PACKET SO
NO MATTER WHAT REGIONAL CENTER
YOU GO INTO THAT EVERY PERSON
WHO GOES TO ACCESS EARLY START
SERVICES OR LETTERMAN SERVICES.
THAT THEY RECEIVE THE SAME
INFORMATION THAT INFORMATION
PACKET IS INTENDED TO HAVE A
DESCRIPTION OF SERVICES. THEIR
RIGHTS WHERE THEY CAN CALL IF
THEY DON'T HAVE THOSE THE
EXPERIENCE THAT THEY NEED TO
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO- ACCESS
THOSE SERVICES SO IT WOULD
INCLUDE DISABILITY RIGHTS
INFORMATION. AS WELL AS BEING
ABLE TO NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM
THAT BY ITSELF DOESN'T ANSWER
ALL THE QUESTIONS. SO IN
ADDITION WE'RE WORKING ON A-
SURVEY A QUICK SURVEY THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO- FAMILIES
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ABOUT THEIR
INITIAL- EXPERIENCE AND
ENTERING INTO THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM- SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THOSE
AREAS WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. ONE OF THE OTHER
AREAS THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
I'M I'M PARTICULARLY- EXCITED
ABOUT NOT HAVING AVAILABLE TO
THE COMMUNITY AS OUR RE
ORGANIZATION. WE HAD HEARD FROM
A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
THE BENEFIT OF HAVING- ONE OF
THE DEPARTMENT STAFF BEING
PRESENT. YOU KNOW IN THE
COMMUNITY TO BE ABLE TO HEAR
WHAT THE CONCERT CONCERNS ARE
AND TO BE ABLE TO REACT IN A
TIMELY WAY. BECAUSE WE HADN'T
ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO I'M REACT
IN A TIMELY WAY TO NOT ONLY
CAN- CONSUMER AND FAMILY
CONCERNS BUT ALSO THAN TO HELP
THE REGIONAL CENTERS. TO BE
ABLE TO HELP THOSE RESOURCES TO
DO THE JOB THAT THEY NEED TO
DO. SO WITHIN OUR ORGANIZATION
AND WE HAD FIFTH FOR NEW
BECAUSE IT. AND THE MAJORITY OF
THEM ARE NOW LOCATED INTO A NEW
ALL SINCE. FOREIGN SO WE'RE HAD
FOR DIFFERENT LAYERS ON FOR THE
TWO ONE REGIONAL SO. WE NOW
HAVE. DIFFERENT SIGNED. THAT
ARE WORKING WITH ALL OF THE
RESULTS. SO WE NOW HAVE ALREADY
STARTED IMPLEMENTING CHANGES
WHERE WE'RE- AT ALL OF THE
REACH CENTER. MEETING WE
ATTENDING THAT CAN MEETING WHEN
IT'S RELATE TO ANY OF DESPAIR
FUNDS DISCUSSED. FROM THE
COMMUTER AND ALSO ABLE TO
RESPOND TO ANY OF THE
COMPLAINTS THAT ARE COMING IN.
IS IT FULLY IMPLEMENTED NO BUT
IT WOULD CERTAINLY IS- PRETTY
FAR ALONG THE WAY- MOVING
FORWARD AS FAR AS ADDITIONAL
KEY INITIATIVES- IN AREAS IN
WHICH WE HAVE PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS YEAR. A
GETTING REALLY DID STEM FROM
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE
HAD WITH THE COMMUNITY AND THE
DIFFERENT ARENAS THAT I'VE
TALKED ABOUT. AND THAT IS A
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVES-
PROPOSAL FOR- THE PERFORMANCE
AND SENT. GRAHAM IT REALLY IS
MOVING IN OUR SYSTEM TO A WAY
TO MEASURE WHAT MATTERS TO
INDIVIDUALS AND THE FAMILIES.
AND TO BE ABLE TO GET IT IN A-
IN A FRAMEWORK IN WHICH IS
GOING TO BE DATA DRIVEN. BUT
IT'S ALSO GOING TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO WHAT ARE THOSE
QUALITATIVE EXPERIENCES THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE FACING. SO AS
WE'RE DEVELOPING THE MODEL IT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITY. IDENTIFY WHAT ARE
THOSE AREAS IN WHICH THEY WANT
TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE ARE BEING
INFORMED BY THAT WE CAN THEN
INFORM YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
AND OTHERS TO SAY HOW ARE WE
MEASURING AND ACCOUNTABLE FOR.
NOT ONLY THE FUNDS THAT ARE
BEING SPENT BUT MAKING SURE
THAT INDIVIDUALS YOU KNOW HAVE
THE SERVICES THAT- BEING
IDENTIFIED WHETHER IT'S IN THE
I PP OR ARMENIAN NEEDS.
NAVIGATE OTHER SYSTEMS SO AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH WE ARE WE I
MEAN THAT OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH OUR COMMUNITY. VERY
QUICKLY I DON'T WANT TO SPEND
TOO MUCH TIME ON A BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU HAVE. MANY OF AT ONE
PROVIDE PUBLIC. BUT ARE
DEVELOPMENTS. TO FORCE IS GOING
TO BE REALLY AND- IN THAT
ENGAGEMENT. OUR PRIOR DEVELOP
IT'LL SERVE TASK FORCE THAT WAS
STRUCTURED- REALLY TO ADDRESS
THE SERVICE SYSTEM. WAS WAS A
REALLY GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE US INPUT. THAT
HELPED INFORM OUR POLICIES
MOVING FORWARD- IT WAS A- I.
DON'T HAVE THE EXACT NUMBER BUT
I THINK IT WAS WE HAD AROUND
THIRTY EIGHT PARTICIPANTS THAT
WERE ON THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE. WHEN WE-
WHEN OUT THIS TIME I WANTED TO
DO AN APPLICATION PROCESS AND
WE DID- I'M GLAD WE DID BUT WE
ALSO RECEIVED OVER TWO HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS. SO I THERE'S OF
OTHER THINGS THAT WAS REAL. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD. ONE IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE TASK
FORCE AND- WAS REALLY
REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR COMMUNITY
WE NEED TO TEND TO THAT A
LITTLE BIT FROM WHAT OUR
PREVIOUS FOCUS WAS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE NOW ALSO
FOCUSING ON ALSO THE YOUNGER
FAMILIES TAKING A LOOK AT SOME
OF THOSE AREAS WHERE WE'RE
HEARING THAT THERE'S- CONCERNS
AND THAT WERE WERE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
GEOGRAPHIC DIFFERENCES AND THE
DIFFERENT ETHNIC DIFFERENCES.
SO WE THEN SAID LET'S GO AHEAD
AND EMBRACES MANY OF THE-
APPLICANTS AS WE COULD WE HAVE
A HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
PARTICIPANTS. SO WE HAVE OUR DS
TASK FORCE AND THEN WE HAVE THE
FIVE DIFFERENT WORK GROUPS WILL
BE ADDRESSING MANY OF THE
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE FOCUSING ON OF OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS. SYSTEM
IN FISCAL REFORM LOOKING AT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
SERVICE ACCESS AND- OUR
DISPARITY EFFORTS. SO AS WE
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS WERE
WERE PLEASE THAT WE HAVE A GOOD
REPRESENTATION- BUT SO LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING ABLE TO WORK
WITH OUR COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE MORE SELF ADVOCATE.
WILL BE. FOREVER TAPE THANK YOU
TO SEND THAT AREA SO. AS WE DO
MORE MORE WORK LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THIS CAN. AND OUR
COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
RIGHT. THE AREA IN WHICH WE
NEED TO BE IN FOR BY SO WE CAN
MOVE WITH THE. THANK YOU NANCY
ANY QUESTIONS MOM. THEY WERE
SHARED AND THANK YOU MADAM
DIRECTOR FOR THE COPPER. UP THE
YOU TOUCHED ON THE RATE STUDY
I'VE BEEN FOR ON THE JUST IN
TERMS IN FOR OUR BUT DISCUSS TO
THE DEPART HAVE SOME ACTIONABLE
ITEMS FROM THAT RATE STUDY WHAT
ARE THE NEXT STEPS. FOR THAT
REPORT SO IT DOESN'T SIT ON A
SHELF IT'S ACTUALLY NOT SEEING
SOME LIFE IN THE DECISIONS THAT
WE MAKE AND- IS THERE A OF A
GROWING RECOGNITION OF LOOKING
AT COST STRUCTURE CAN I COME
FROM A VERY HIGH COST COUNTY
SAN MATEO COUNTY AND- ON JUST
THE DIFFICULTY IN PAYING
PROVIDERS IN A SUPER HIGH COST
AREA I APPRECIATE YOU TOUCHING
ON THE HOUSING ISSUE THAT'S- ON.
YOU KNOW NOT A DAY GOES THAT WE
DON'T TINK ABOUT THIS AND FOR
THE ID COMMUNITY- CARVING OUT-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
OPPORTUNITIES IS HUGE- OF A
CONTINUING CONVERSATION BUT
JUST IN TERMS OF-
REGIONALIZATION AND LOOKING AT
THE COST STRUCTURING AND- PAIN
PROVIDERS APPROPRIATELY- WHERE
MIGHT WE GO. WITH C. S. SOME OF
THE CONCLUSIONS FROM THE RATE
STUDY. THANK YOU FOR THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN-
THE RATE STUDY DID INFORM SOME
OF THE DISCUSSIONS THAT YIELDED
THE UP TO A POINT 2% FROM A
MANY OF THE SERVICE CODES-
CURRENT YEAR- WE ADDED WITH THE
UPDATED RIGHT MODELS- AND
FISCAL WE'RE ABLE TO IDENTIFY.
IDENTIFY THREE ADDITIONAL
SERVICE CODES TO TWO OF THEM
TOUCH EARLY START AND ONE IS
INDEPENDENT LIVING. TO WHICH IS
PROPOSED FOR ADDING TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE ADJUSTMENT DO
YOU RECALL LAST YEAR WAS FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WENT TOWARDS.
TOTAL FUND FOR THOSE AND THEN
THIS YEAR- FOR HALF A YEAR IT'S
EIGHTEEN MILLION I THIRTY FIVE
MILLION FOR WHICH WOULD BE AN
ANNUALIZED AMOUNT. SO BUT THE
NEXT STEPSTHAT WERE I MEAN AS
THE AS A DEPARTMENT THAT
DISCUSSION TAKING IT TO OUR
SYSTEM INFILL REFORM DISCUSSION
REALLY LOOKING MORE AS A SYSTEM.
AS FAR AS WHERE THEY PRESSURE
SO MUCH WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
IDENTIFY NEXT STEPS THEN FOCUS
RIGHT NOW ON THAT PER. AND SON
PROGRAM THE SEVEN EIGHT MILLION
THAT'S PROPOSED THIS YEAR. IN
REALLY TAKEN A LOOK AT THE
FRAMEWORK OF HOW DO WE STILL
FELT THE SYSTEM TO FORWARD THAT
IS TOUCHING ON REBELS AND A
FINE WAYS THAT WE MEASURE THE
PROGRESS. THANK YOU THEN I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS ALSO WE
LOOK AT THE HIGH COST. AREAS TO
PERFORM SERVICES. AT SOME OF
THESE LOW CUT LOCATIONS HAVE A
HIGHER MINIMUM WAGE WE TALK
ABOUT THE EIGHT POINT TWO
PERCENT. YOU ALSO HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE A THE HIGHER
MINIMUM WAGE IN THAT EQUATION.
AS IS BEING UNFAIR- WAY TO
APPROACH THAT I THINK THAT WE
pCAN LOOK THAT IN THE BUDGET GO
FORWARD. BUT I BEEN A BY SO OF
OUR PER. THAT THE BOTH HAVE TO
BE MEDICAL. YOU KNOW IF YOU
AGAIN YOU KNOW YOU STARTED A
RESPITE WORKER YOU ACT YOU KNOW
IT'S WHAT ROOF COLLEAGUES FROM
REGISTER RACKS HAVE WORKING
KNOWLEDGE OF THE WHOLE FAT OF
WHAT SHE ACTUALLY NOW RECEIVE.
AND WHICH MAY OF ORIGINS HERE
HAS HAD THAT KIND OF WORKING
KNOWLEDGE. AND IT I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE AND
WORKING WITH US SO ALL YOU FOR
THE ARE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO
THE- CALIFORNIA LOTTERY CYPRUS.
WITH THE- EARNINGS. ARE
PRINCIPAL WATER. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE LARA. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LAURA KERNEY
AND I AM AN AUDIT PRINCIPLE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE THE COMMITTEE
ASKED US 2% TODAY INFORMATION
PERTAINING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
IMPLEMENTATION OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE'VE MADE
IN RECENT REPORTS THAT WE FOR
AT LEAST. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I DID IS I WENT BACK TEN
YEARS TO IDENTIFY JUST HOW MANY-REPORTS WE'VE RELEASED AND
WE'VE RELEASED A TOTAL FIVE
REPORTS REGARDING DDS IT'S
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THOUGH
THAT SOME OF THESE REPORTS ARE
A FEW YEARS OLD THE MOST RECENT
REPORT WAS RELEASED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THESE REPORTS
COVERED A VARIETY OF TOPICS
INCLUDING DTS ES OVERSIGHT OF
REGIONAL CENTERS AS WELL AS ITS
ADMINISTRATION OF IN HOME
RESPITE SERVICES NOW THESE
REPORTS RESULTED IN A TOTAL OF
FORTY SIX RECOMMENDATIONS TO
DDS AND THEY'VE HAD A
RELATIVELY HIGH IMPLEMENTATION
RATE THEY HAVE IMPLEMENTED
THIRTY NINE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE TO
THEM. THERE ARE THREE THAT THEY
ARE STILL WORKING TO IMPLEMENT
IT AND THE RESULT OF OUR MOST
RECENT REPORT TO BE RELEASED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND THERE
ARE ANOTHER FOR THAT THEY HAVE
STATED THAT THEY WILL NOT
IMPLEMENT I WAS GOING TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH A LITTLE BIT
MORE INFORMATION. TO THOSE
OTHER RECOMMENDATION BUT I DID
WANT TO TOUCH ON FIRST OF ALL
WHAT ARE THE GOALS OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. REALLY A LOT
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE'VE
MADE FOCUS ON INCREASING
OVERSIGHT BY DD UPS AND ALSO
ENSURING THAT THE REGIONAL
CENTER. CONSISTENT PROCESS IS
SURE THE THEY'RE FIGHTING CAN
ALREADY SIR THIS I IN ADDITION
OUR RECORD. AS IT IS TO ANY TO
IS REALLY TO IMPROVE ACTIVE
NISSEN EFFICIENT AND GOVERNOR
IN THOSE STATION LAMP TED ALL
OF. OFFER. ON THE STATUS OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN WE
FOLLOW UP AGAIN EVERY YEAR
THEREAFTER FOR A PERIOD OF FIVE
YEARS- THE ENTITIES PROVIDE US
WITH SUPPORTING DOCUMENTATION
AND THEN WE ASSESS. THE STATUS
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THOUGH
THAT THE MAJORITY OF THE
REPORTS THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
HERE TODAY HAVE ALREADY RUN
THROUGH THAT CYCLE. WE ONLY
HAVE THE ONE REMAINING FROM TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THAT WERE
STILL FOLLOWING UP ON. NOW AS
IT RELATES TO THAT REPORT- WE
CONDUCTED A REPORT A REGARDING
IN HOME RESPITE SERVICES AS I
INDICATED IT WAS RELEASED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. WE FOUND
A COUPLE OF SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
ONE IT WAS NOT KENTUCKY
CONDUCTING FISCAL AUDITS OF
REGIONAL CENTERS THAT IT'S
REQUIRED TO DO EVERY TWO YEARS
WITH IN A TIMELY MANNER WE
RECOMMENDED THAT EFFECTS THAT.
I IN ADDITION. READ CENTERS
MUST REVIEW VENDORS OR
PROVIDERS FILES EVERY TWO YEARS
THAT'S A FORM OF OVERSIGHT THAT
THE REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE OVER
VENDORS. AND WE FOUND THAT
THOSE REVIEWS BASED ON OUR
REVIEW OF FIVE REGIONAL CENTERS
WERE NOT OCCURRING- OR IF THEY
WERE OCCURRING THEY COULDN'T
DEMONSTRATE TO US THAT THEY HAD
ACTUALLY HAPPENED. SO WE
RECOMMENDED TO DDS AT THE
INSURER THAT DIGITAL CENTERS
HAVE A PROCESS IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THOSE REVIEWS OF HER.
AYE DDS AGREED TO IMPLEMENT
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONSBACK IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THEY'RE
STILL WORKING ON THAT AND THEY
SAID. THAT THEY WILL IMPLEMENT
THEM FULLY BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR IN DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY.
I WANTED TO GIVE YOU JUST A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES TO OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THE DDS THAT
THEY WOULDN'T EMPLOYMENT. I
THINK THAT CAN BE INSIGHTFUL.
IT'S IMPORTANT POINT OUT THOUGH
THAT THESE RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
MADE NEARLY TEN YEARS AGO- BUT
WE STILL STAND BY THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. WHEN DR AUDIT
TO TEN WHICH WAS A- RAW. BUT IT.
UP WE DIE YES IS OVER I OF READ
SKINNER. ACTION I VENDORS OF
FOUND SOMETHING KINDS. OF FOR.
WE FOR SOME INDICATION THERE
WAS FOR. BY REGIONAL CENTERS
WHEN SELECTING VENDORS AND OF
COURSE THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS A
SURE THAT YOU'RE PROVIDING HIGH
SCHOOL THE SERVICES. ARE ANSWER.
WELL FOUND THAT HE'D DIDN'T A
PROPER TO OVER. HOW CENTERS
WERE SELECTING VENDORS SO WE
MADE RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS
THOSE TWO AREAS OF CONCERN BUT
EDS STATED THAT IT DIDN'T
BELIEVE IT HAD THE AUTHORITY TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. WHICH IS A
POSITION THAT OUR OFFICE
STRONGLY. DISAGREED WITH AND
STILL DOES- TODAY UP AND I ALSO
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT WHEN
THOSE TYPES OF RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE MADE WE MISS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO INCREASE TRANSPARENCY. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. FINALLY WHEN I
WANT TO TOUCH ON IS THE FACT
THAT WE ALSO MAKE LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS. I IN THE
REPORTS OF DISCUSS HERE TO. WE
MADE A TOTAL SEVEN. A ONE OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN
ACTED ON BY THE LEGISLATURE- IN
TYPICALLY WE MAKE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WHEN WE
IDENTIFY A NEED FOR A POLICY
CHANGE OR WE NEED TO COMPEL THE
DEPARTMENT. TO AT LEAST FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH A RECOMMENDATION
THAT WE BELIEVE WARRANTS
LEGISLATIVE CHANGE SO AS AN
EXAMPLE IN THAT IN THAT TWO
THOUSAND TEN REPORT I JUST
DESCRIBED TO YOU WE CONDUCTED A
FOLLOW UP IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. AND IN THAT REPORT WE
IDENTIFY THE SAME ISSUES THAT
WE HAD PREVIOUSLY NO OVERSIGHT
OF REGIONAL CENTERS VENDOR
SELECTION. AND BECAUSE WE KNEW
THAT DDS WAS GOING TO MAINTAIN
THE POSITION THAT THEY DIDN'T
BELIEVE THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO DO THAT WE MADE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE. TO TRY TO COMPEL
THE DEPARTMENT TO ACTUALLY
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH THAT
OVERSIGHT ULTIMATELY THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE STILL
OUTSTANDING BUT AGAIN WE STAND
BY THEM. THEY WOULD INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN CLOSING I
WANTED I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THE REPORTS I COVER TODAY.
WE'RE SOMEWHAT NARROW IN SCOPE
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND TEN AUDIT. THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AUDIT FOCUSED
ON A VERY SMALL PROGRAM- IN
TERMS OF DDS A SPENDING ONLY
FIVE PERCENT. OF ITS DIRECT
SERVICES BUDGET GOES TO IN HOME
RESPITE SERVICES AS A VERY
NARROW SCOPE. OF THE OTHER
REPORT THAT WE DID THAT I'VE
TOUCHED ON TODAY TEN YEARS AGO.
OF THE LEGISLATURE MAY DECIDE
THAT NOW'S A GOOD TIME TO
CONDUCT ANOTHER STATE AUDIT. WE
HAVE NEW LEADERSHIP A DDS AS
EVIDENCED BY THE DIRECTOR WHO
JUST SPOKE HERE BEFORE ME-
THERE COULD BE DIFFERENT TONE
FROM THE TOP. A IT WOULD BE
VALUE ADDED TO POSSIBLY TRY TO
IDENTIFY. HOW DIFFICULT IT
COULD BE FOR A CONSUMER TO
NAVIGATE- THE REGIONAL CENTERS
AND TRIED TO OBTAIN SERVICES
FROM THEM. IT ALSO MIGHT BE.
BENEFICIAL TO DETERMINE WHAT
TYPE OF OVERSIGHT REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE PROVIDING OF
VENDORS. AND THE SAME WITH EDS
AS OVERSIGHT OF REGIONAL
CENTERS ALL WITH THE GOAL OF
COURSE OF INCREASING THE
QUALITY OF SERVICES. THE
CONSUMERS ARE RECEIVING. OF THE
STATE AUDITOR OF COURSE TO BE
HAPPY TO CONDUCT ANY AUDIT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REQUESTS. AND
ANOTHER OF A VERY POSITIVE
ASPECT OF AN AUDIT OF COURSE IS
THAT WE ARE INDEPENDENT WE ARE
NONPARTISAN. AND WE CONDUCT OUR
REVIEWS IN ACCORDANCE WITH
RIGOROUS STANDARDS. SO I JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT THOSE FACTS
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE THAT DOES
CONCLUDE MY TESTIMONY. ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE FOR.
POSTED MON MISMAS WEBER AVE I
WANT TO THANK YOU AYE AYE IT'S
NOT NECESSARY FOR THAT I'M
GONNA HAVE TO GO TO ANOTHER
MEETING BUT I JUST WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO WAS HERE FOR
YOU SEE ME SNEAK OUT TO THE
NEXT MEETING HAVE A BUDGET
MEETING BUT- I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAS COME OUT IN AND
MR MULLIN REMINDED US THAT
WE'RE IN AN OPPORTUNE WIN IT A
WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY. TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE'VE HAD AND IT'S INTERESTING
BE I'D CARE MOST YEAR THE
BUDGET WHAT FIVE YEARS AGO OR
SO AND MANY OF THESE ISSUES
STILL REMAIN IN TERMS OF
FUNDING AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE WE'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING AND OBVIOUSLY THE
CONSTANT TURNOVER BECAUSE WOULD
NOT ADEQUATELY FUNDING AND IN
TERMS OF STAFF OF THE CENTERS
REGIONAL CENTERS AND ALL THOSE
THINGS AND I I'M JUST HOPEFUL
THAT THIS YEAR. WE WILL DO
BETTER THAN WE'VE DONE IN THE
LAST FOUR FEET OR SO IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO CREATE THE
NECESSARY FUNDING THAT WILL
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT ARE
SO ESSENTIAL FOR THOSE IN THE
STATE THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ASSIST AND
HELPING THEM HAVE THE KIND OF
LIFE THAT ALL OF US EXPECT TO
HAVE SO I REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR SHARING THAT
INFORMATION- WITH US- WITH ME
TODAY AND AS IS ONE OF THE
CHEERS OF THE BUDGET. I WILL
DEFINITELY- BE LOOKING VERY
CAREFULLY AT WHAT WE'VE DONE
WHETHER THAT WERE RESPONDING TO
THESE ISSUES THAT ARE SO
CRITICAL MANY THE ISSUES YOU
RAISE CAN BE SOLVED SOMETIMES
BY BY MORE FUNDING JUST TO BE
VERY HONEST ABOUT IT BECAUSE I
FOUND WORKING WITH MY REGIONAL
CENTER THERE'S SOME REALLY
WONDERFUL PEOPLE WHO WORK AT
THE REGIONAL CENTERS. THERE
THERE THERE THERE AND THEIR
SACRIFICES MENTALLY BECAUSE OF
THE LOW PAY THAT WE PROVIDE
THEM AND SO SOMETIMES PEOPLE
HAVE TO LEAVE BECAUSE THEY GET
A DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITY WORKING
FOR THE COUNTY OR SOME OF THE
SERVICE AND UP AND THAT HARD
BREAK WITH THOSE WHO HAVE TO
CONTENTS OF WORK. WE HAVE OVER.
THE REAL LOOK AT AND WE WANT TO.
WE HAVE TO. IN TERMS OF. THIS
IS REALLY THE TWO IN THE FOR TO
DO. THE BRACELET AWAY FROM US
AND WE A SO EVEN AND CAN. THE
NEXT COUPLE OF SO I'M THAT ARE
COMMITTEE WILL BE STRONG. FOR
THAT AND THAT THOSE OF US ON
THE WILL RECOGNIZE THAT AND I
THINK OUR STAFF IS HERE AS WELL
AS THOSE OF YOU WHO'VE COME AND
SHARED SOME WONDERFUL STORIES
WITH US REALLY WONDERFUL
STORIES OF VICTORY. A IN THE
MIDST OF A LOT OF CHALLENGES
THAT YOU HAVE INSIDE ONE THANK
YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU SO
MAYOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AGAIN AS CHAIR AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. WOULD
LOVE TO GET MY HANDS ON THAT
ORIGINAL TWENTY TEN ON IT WHICH
PREDATES MY TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT THE I ACTION
ITEMS LEGISLATIVE THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN ACTED ON WOULD LOVE TO SEE
YOU. AS PRECISELY WHAT THOSE
ARE WHERE WE'VE BEEN DELINQUENT
AND NOT ACTING- IT AND-
THOUSAND. I'M CURIOUS YOU YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE CASE REVIEWS
THAT PART BEING DONE AT THE
REGIONAL CENTERS. CAN YOU
DEFINE OR DESCRIBE WHAT A
REVIEW IS YES THE KEY IS AS
SIMPLE AS- LOOKING THROUGH THE
FILE OR IS THIS AN EXTENSIVE-
LEVEL KIND OF A REVIEW THAT IT
INVOLVES THAT. YOU KNOW
INTERACTION WITH WITH THE
PRIMARY AND OTHER ADVOCATES CAN
YOU DESCRIBE WHAT THAT IS YES
THIS REVIEW IS JUST AS YOU HAD
DESCRIBED IT IS VERY LIMITED.
IT IS SIMPLY TO REVIEWING THE
VENDOR FILE THAT THE REGIONAL
CENTER MAINTAINS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR LICENSING THE
CERTIFICATIONS ARE UP TO DATE
THAT THEY HAVE A CURRENT
SERVICE DELIVERY DESIGN. OF
IT'S REALLY LIMITED TO US THAT
AND IT'S NOT TIME CONSUMING
WHAT WE FOUND WHEN WE WENT OUT
TO THE FIVE REGIONAL CENTERS IS
THAT'S A COUPLE WEREN'T EVEN
AWARE THAT IT OF THE
REQUIREMENT. AND THAT THEY NEED
TO BE DOING IT SO THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN PART OF THE REASON
THAT IT WASN'T BEING PERFORMED.
OF THE OTHER THREE SIMPLY JUST
DIDN'T HAVE A PROCESS FOR
DOCUMENTING THE REVIEWS BUT
THEY ARE CRITICAL BECAUSE WHEN
WE WENT THROUGH THOSE FILES WE
FOUND THAT SOME DIDN'T HAVE
UPDATED INFORMATION. AND THE
RISK OF COURSE IS THAT YOU HAVE
VENDORS PROVIDING SERVICES TO
CONSUMERS. WHO ARE NOT
QUALIFIED AND MEET FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. THANK YOU AND
I'LL GO BACK TO WHAT I'VE SAID
IN OTHER HEARINGS WHEN IS WHEN
WE HAD TO THE STATE AUDITOR.
THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA REALLY
NEED TO THINK THE STATE AUDITOR
FOR BEING THAT ADVOCATE FOR
THEM IN A YOU KNOW A NON BIASED
A- ARENA. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT- I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
TODAY'S WHEN YOU SEE THIS IS
GLARINGLY ABSENT IS WE HAVE NO
PROVIDERS THAT ARE ACTUALLY. ON
A PANEL. AND THEY DIDN'T WANT
TO SHOW UP TODAY FOR FEAR OF
REPRISAL. AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
AFRAID OF VOICING OF HOW THEY
FEEL THEY'VE BEEN TREATED OR OR
ANY OF THAT KIND OF MANNER AND
SO WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS SHOULD
SHARE THAT. THEY'RE NOT HERE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
AFRAID OF BEING A PUNISHED IN
DIFFERENT LOCALES AND- AND THAT
THAT'S BEEN. KIND OF A COP
GLARING THING THAT'S WE'VE
NOTICES THE HEARINGS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- AND THAT'S NOT TO
SAY IT HAPPENS EVERYWHERE I'M
JUST SAYING THAT THIS IS WHAT
HAS BEEN KIND OF THE NORM FOR
US. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK THAT I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IS THOUGH AND I.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF GOING INTO THE
FISCAL ANNA AND THE OVERSIGHT
OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS. BUT
I'VE HAD THE THOUGHT OF MAYBE
THE STATE AUDITOR WOULD B ABLE
TO COME IN FROM THE CLIENTS
PERSPECTIVE AND WORK FOR THE
CLIENT. BACK TO THE REGIONAL
CENTER IN AN AUDIT. AND SEEING
HOW AND WHERE THEY COULD BE
DEFICIENCIES FROM THAT GOING
FORWARD. AND I THINK THAT WOULD
BE. KIND OF VALIDATION OR- AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US AS WELL AS
LEGISLATORS TO SEE HOW. OUR
EXPECTATION FOR OUTCOMES IS
BEING PROVIDED. OR NOT. SO I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TALK TO J.
LACK ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY. OF
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT.
THAT OVERSIGHT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR. TO MAKE SURE THAT.
ASSIST FUNDING PARTNERS. THAT
WE'RE ACTUALLY GETTING. THE
BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR BUCK IN
VALUE. AND SO AGAIN THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH FOR COMING TODAY
WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOU AND
YOUR DEPARTMENT- FOR GUIDING US
AND THEN ON A REAL PERSPECTIVE
ON HOW. THINGS REALLY ARE. YOU
FOR HAVING ME AND MR MULLIN
I'LL GET YOU THAT REPORT.
COMING UP TO OUR LAST PANEL IT
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE
STATEWIDE STATEWIDE DISABILITY
ADVOCATES THE CITY COUNCIL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
CINDY SMITH. AND JUST WHAT
BILLY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA KATIE
HORNBERGER OF FROM THE DIRECTOR
OF OUR CLIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCACY.
WE'RE GONNA START OFFICE IN THE
FIRST. GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON HELLO CHEN FRAZIER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY MY NAME IS CINDY
SMITH I AM THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR POLICY AND PUBLIC AFFAIRS
AT THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THE
COUNCIL BELIEVES HAVING ACCESS
TO IN RECEIVING QUALITY
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS AS THE
CORNERSTONE FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO
BE SAFE HEALTHY ENSURE SELF
DETERMINATION. ANY DISCUSSION
OF POLICY PARTIES MUST FOCUS ON
THE VALUES OTHER DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND RIGHTS
ASSISTANCE ACTS THAT CREATES
THE DD COUNCIL AS WELL AS THE
LANHAM ACT INCLUDING CHOICE AND
INCLUSION. YOU HAVE THE
OPPORUNITY HERE TODAY IT'S
HARD TO FOLLOW TO SELF
ADVOCATES THAT ARE ON THE
COUNCIL WAS THE WEATHER SPOON
IN ROSY RYAN. I BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS NO ONE BETTER TO
INFORM THIS COMMITTEE OF WHAT
IMPROVEMENTS NEED TO BE MADE TO
THE SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE
SERVICES FROM THE SYSTEM. STIR
WITHERSPOON. AND MS RYAN RAISE
A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT ISSUES
FROM THE PERSONAL EXPERIENCES
NO TESTIMONY. AND I'M HOPING IN
PLEASE BILL ROVIDES ADDITIONAL
RECOMMENDATIONS OF SOLUTIONS
FROM THE COUNCIL TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE COUNCIL PROVIDE A
GRANT TO CREATE A STATEWIDE
STRATEGIC FRAMEWORK ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS FOR
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AS MR WHETHER
SING STATED WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES
WHO ARE CURRENTLY LIVING AT
HOME WITH AGING CARE GIVERS
HEARING CALIFORNIA. THE NUMBER
ONE RECOMMENDATION THE
COUNCIL'S FRAMEWORK WAS TO
CREATE A DEDICATED HOUSING FUND
FOR PEOPLE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. THE FRAMEWORK. IN
CONCLUDED THAT WE NEED TWENTY
THOUSAND NEW UNITS. THE
COUNCIL'S WORKING ON A PROPOSAL
TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS
BY CREATING A ONE TIME FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
GENERAL FUND HOUSING FUND AS
PART OF THE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAM. THE FUNDING
WILL PROVIDE GAPS FUNDING FOR
APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE UNITS ARMY
11% OF THE TOTAL NEED. FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION IS THE SAME
AMOUNT THAT WAS PROVIDED BY THE
MENTAL HEALTH TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH COMMUNITY IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT. CHANGING
TO THE TOPIC OF EMPLOYMENT
MISTER WITHERSPOON OFFER A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS
RELATED FROM PLANET BUT I OFFER
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SURVEY REPORT THE
EMPLOYMENT RATE. OF WORKING AGE
PEOPLE WITHOUT DISABILITIES WAS
77% BOTH ANY TYPE OF DISABILITY
IT WAS THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT.
HOWEVER FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
RECEIVE SERVICES FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM THE
PERCENTAGE IS ONLY INCREASED BY
ABOUT 2% 216% IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. COUNCIL BELIEVES IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT THE STATE
CREATE ACROSS AGENCY STATEWIDE
EMPLOYMENT STRATEGY. FOR PEOPLE
DISABILITIES WITH BENCHMARKS
FOR HOW TO INCREASE THE
EMPLOYMENT PARTICIPATION RATE
EACH YEAR TO GET CLOSER TO OUR
GOAL OF HAVING AN EMPLOYMENT
PARTICIPATION RATE FOR PEOPLE
WITHOUT DISABILITIES. THAT IS
SIMILAR TO THAT OF PERSONS
WITH. OUT JUST. HAVING INCLUDES
PATIENT RATE SOMEWHERE FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
SIMILAR TO THAT WITHOUT
DISABILITIES. AND COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATE IMPLEMENT. IN
ADDITION THE STATE NEEDS TO
CONTINUE ITS COMBAT MEANT TO
MAKING CALIFORNIA MODEL
EMPLOYER FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. AND WHILE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE NEEDED AND WE
BELIEVE THE PROGRAM NEEDS TO BE
STRENGTHENED AT MINIMUM THE
LIMITED EDUCATION APPOINTMENT.
OR THE PROGRAM IMPEDE ENGINE
TRIP PROGRAM OPTIONS THAT ARE
SET TO SUNSET AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE MUST BE CONTINUED I CAN
REPORT TO THE COUNCIL THAT WE
HAVE HAD MULTIPLE STAFF WHO
APPLIED THROUGH THE LEAGUE
PROGRAM UNDERSTOOD CECILIE BEEN
EMPLOYED AT THE COUNCIL. IN
TURN THE CONVERSATION OF RATES.
THE COUNCIL FULLY SUPPORTS. THE
NEEDS TO FULLY RESTORE AND
PROVIDE RATE INCREASES TO
STABILIZE THE SYSTEM AND ENSURE
THE AVAILABILITY OF QUALITY
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. THE
COUNCIL ALSO BELIEVE THAT IS-NOT POSSIBLE FOR SERVICES TO BE
TRULY INDIVIDUALIZED WITH THE
CURRENT HE SLOWED RATIOS AND
EACH REGIONAL CENTER. THE CASE
ROAD RATIOS NEED TO BE FULLY
ADDRESSED THE COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE CASELOAD
RATIOS THE COUNCIL IS PLEASED
TO SEE THE PROPOSAL FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. IN ANY ADEQUATE AND
COMPREHENSIVE SAFE AND NOT IS
NEEDED THAT CAN MEET LEE
UNTIMELY ADDRESS MEDICAL
BEHAVIORAL AND OTHER NEEDS. IS
A NECESSITY THAT WE MUST HAVE
AGAIN THE COUNCIL'S HAPPY TO
SEE THE STEPS LIMóN TAKEN IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. TO
IMPROVE THE SAFETY NET. THE
COUNCIL IN ITS ROLE AS A GRANT
MAKER THIS YEAR FUNDED A GRANT
TO CREATE SERVICE OUTCOMES
SPELL TAKEN ACCOUNT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S PERSONAL GOALS FOR
THEMSELVES. THE COUNCIL
BELIEVES THAT IS CRITICAL TO
CREATE CLEARLY DEFINED.
CONSISTENT AND MEASURABLE
SERVICE OUTCOMES TO IMPROVE
SERVICES. TRAINING IN
PURCHASING. THE GRANT IS KNOWN
AS THE PERSON CENTERED ADVOCACY
VISION AND EDUCATION OR PAVE
PROJECT LEVEL PEOPLE COMPLICATE
ACRONYMS. THE GRANT IS
DEVELOPING ITS FRAMEWORK USING
WHAT WE KNOW TO BE A CBS
COMPLIANCE SERVICES. THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
MEDICAID RULE GOES INTO EFFECT
IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
AND THE RULES FOCUSED ON
CREATING A DEFINITION OF EACH
CBS THAT IS BASED ON THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE SETTING.
THIS MUST COME INTO COMPLIANCE
OR RISK LOSING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. THE PAVE PROJECT
GRANTEES WILL PROVIDE TO THE
COUNCIL AT THE END OF SEPTEMBER
OR THE UNDER THE FEDERAL FISCAL
YEAR FRAMEWORK FOR DELIVERY.
MEASUREMENT AND IMPROVEMENT OF
THE SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM
INCLUDING HOW TO MOVE THE RATE
STUDY FORWARD THE FILL THE GAP
CITED IN THE RATE STUDY IN
REGARDS SO MAKING SERVICE
PROVIDER PAYMENTS TO QUALITY
SERVICE OUTCOMES. THAT SAID
IT'S CRITICAL OF THE SYSTEM
CONTINUE TO BE STABILIZED GIVEN
THE OUTCOMES OF THE RATE STUDY
THE COUNCIL THANKS YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES FOR THE SUPPORT THE
RATE INCREASES LAST YEAR. BUT
BELIEVES MORE MUST BE DONE TO
CONTINUE TO STABILIZE THE
SYSTEM. THE COUNCIL'S HOPEFUL
AT THE FRAMEWORK WILL PROVIDE
THE STATE IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS
WITH SERVICE OUTCOMES. THAT THE
STATE WILL BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
BASED ON THE VALUES OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
BILL OF RIGHTS ASSISTANCE ACT
IN THE LANHAM ACT. TO ENSURE
THE PURCHASING IS BASED ON
QUALITY. THAT WE TARGET
RESOURCES WHERE THEY ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN THE MEASURE THE
RESULTS OF THOSE SERVICE
OUTCOMES. IN ADDITION WE
BELIEVE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CENTER BY SERVICES BUT
ALLOW PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES TO TRANSITION TO
LESS RESTRICTIVE PROGRAMS OR
SERVICES FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CREATE AN
INCENTIVE FOR PROVIDERS. WHO
SUCCESSFULLY HELP TRANSITION A
PERSON FROM A SUB MINIMUM WAGE
POSITION TO SUPPORT EMPLOYMENT
IN A GROUP SETTING OR SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT IN A GROUP SETTING
TO COMPETITIVE INTEGRATE
IMPLEMENT. THE COUNCIL ALSO
BELIEVE THE IMPLEMENTATION THE
RATE STUDY SHOULD BE USED AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A CAREER
OPPORTUNITY WITH ADVANCEMENT
FOR DISABILITY SERVICE
PROVIDERS. WE NEED TO CREATE A
PIPELINE TALENTED DISABILITY
SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO SEE A
SUSTAINABLE CAREER PATH FOR
THEMSELVES AND PROVIDING DIRECT
SERVICE THE COUNCIL BELIEVES IT
IS TIME TO CREATE TRAINING AND
CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS FOR
PROVIDERS AND PROVIDER SHOULD
RECEIVE HIGHER WAGES. BASED ON
THE REGIONAL TRAINING OR
CREDENTIALS THEY RECEIVE. THE
COUNCIL APPRECIATES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO SHARE
OUR PERSPECTIVES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS IN PARTICULAR
ON THE RATE STUDY AS WE FINISH
OUR PAVE PROJECT AND ARE ABLE
TO HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE. TO THE LEGISLATURE
IN SEPTEMBER THANK YOU THANK
YOU. KATIE THANK FOR HAVING US.
UP SO AND YOU KNOW I KATIE HER
HEARD AND DIRECTOR THE OFFICE
OF CLIENTS ADVOCACY WERE FUNDED
THROUGH A CONTRACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TO PROVIDE FREE LEGAL
SERVICES TO REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENTS. OF IT. DEAR SEE
SERVES- CLIENTS THROUGH ALL OF
OUR PROGRAMS INCLUDING MINE-
LAST YEAR WE ASSISTED NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE OF
WHICH MORE THAN TWELVE THOUSAND
IDENTIFIED AS PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY PEOPLE ONLY CALL
US WHEN THINGS DON'T GO WELL.
SO LOOK AT AS YOU SAID EARLIER-
CHAIRMAN YOU KNOW WE DON'T
ALWAYS HEARTHE GOOD THINGS
NOBODY CALLS ME TO TELL ME
THINGS ARE GOING WELL.
UNFORTUNATELY BUT HAVING BEEN
IN THE SYSTEM A LONG TIME- WE
HAVE- REALLY LOOKED AT THE
VALUES THAT HAVE FORMED OUR
SYSTEM. AND TO ME. THE SURE I.
HAVE THAT WE RETURN TO THE
VALUE. AND SHAPE OUR PA. FROM
THE- WHEN WE LOOK TO THE VALUES
THE ARE INCLUDE. INTEGRATION
AND CHOICE. OF AND- THOSE COME
FROM OUR VERY FOUNDATION BACK
IN THE LATE SIXTIES AND HAVE
NEVER LEFT OUR SYSTEM. THOSE
VALUES ARE ALSO EXEMPLIFIED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN BOTH
IN THE SUPREME COURT IN THE
OLMSTEAD DECISION AND IN THE
FINAL RULE FROM THE HUMAN HOME
AND COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES.
DEPARTMENT UP AS YOU KNOW WE
WILL HAVE TO BE IMPLEMENTING
THAT RULE BY MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND TO DO SO
INDIVIDUALS MUST BE INTEGRATED
INTO THE COMMUNITY TO THE SAME
DEGREE AS PEOPLE WITHOUT
DISABILITIES ALL SERVICE
SETTINGS MUST OFFER INCLUSION
AND COMMUNITY INTEGRATION. AND
PLANNING FOR SERVICES NEEDS TO
BE INDIVIDUALLY DETERMINED AND
FOCUSED ON THE PERSON'S UNIQUE
GOALS AND NEEDS. THIS WILL
PARTICULARLY IMPACT SEGREGATED
SITE BASED DAY AND SHELTERED
WORKSHOP PROGRAMS AT WHICH WILL
NEED TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
FUNDING RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
WILL ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES FOR EXAMPLE
PROVIDING CHOICE OF ROOMMATE OR
TO HAVE A SINGLE ROOM. LOCKABLE
DOORS FLEXIBLE MEAL TIMES
FLEXIBLE VISITING HOURS AND
READY ACCESS TO FOOD AS DESIRED
BY THE RESIDENTS WHO LIVE IN
THE HOME. THE OTHER PIECE TO
LOOK AT WHEN WE THINK OF OUR
VALUES IS TO THINK ABOUT WHERE
PEOPLE LIVE GENERALLY. THE
SYSTEM WAS FOUNDED BY PEOPLE
WHO DID NOT WANT TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE THEIR CHILDREN
THEY WANTED A SERVICE SYSTEM
THAT WOULD BE A REALISTIC
ALTERNATIVE. AND KEEP HELP KEEP
THEIR CHILDREN SAFELY AT HOME
AND ALLOW THEIR CHILDREN TO
PROSPER. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMERS OVER
60% OF ADULTS AND 97% OF
CHILDREN LIVE WITH THEIR
FAMILIES. MANY OF WHOM
UNFORTUNATELY OR FORCED TO
PROVIDE UNPAID CARE IN THE FACE
OF AN ADEQUATE SUPPORTS THROUGH
AYE HSS AND OTHER PUBLICLY
FUNDED PROGRAMS. THE PROBLEM IS
MOST ACUTE FOR OUR CLIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES FROM COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND THOSE CAN PEOPLE
WHO DO NOT SPEAK ENGLISH. IN
OUR SYSTEM WE HAVE STAGGERING
SPENDING DISPARITIES. BOTH BY
COLOR AND BY LANGUAGE AND THIS
IS DESPITE MULTI YEAR EFFORTS
TO REDUCE THESE DISPARITIES.
WHEN WE LOOK TO RATE REFORM
EFFORTS. AND THE EFFORTS TO
STRENGTHEN THE PERFORMANCE
MEASURES THIS YEAR THESE MUST
BE TIED TO OUTCOMES THAT WILL
ADVANCE THESE VALUES. OF. AND
WE SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE THE
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
THAT WAS OUTLINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IT THIS
PROPOSAL PRESENTS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
IN THE SERVICE DELIVERY AND IN
THE LIVED EXPERIENCES OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DECEPTIVEELEMENTAL
DISABILITIES WHICH IS WHAT WE
CARE MOST ABOUT IS THE LIVED
EXPERIENCE FOR PEOPLE. AS WE
THINK ABOUT POSSIBLE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES ONCE AGAIN
WE NEED TO GO TO THE VALUES OF
INCREASING COMMUNITY
INTEGRATION INCLUSION AND
CHOICE. WE SHOULD BE
INCENTIVIZING INTEGRATION
RELATED OUTCOMES THAT TAKE A
GREATER URGENCY GIVEN THE TIME
LINE OF THE FINAL RULE.
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED TWO POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
MEDICAID FUNDING TO PROVIDE H.
CBS SERVICES AND AS A CONDITION
OF THIS FUNDING WE NEED TO BE
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE FINAL
RULE WE NEED TO START NOW IN
IMPLEMENTING THE CHANGES TO
THOSE. PROGRAM PROVIDERS. AND
WE CAN DO THAT THROUGH OUR
INCENTIVES. THE PERFORMANCE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM MUST ALSO
REWARD EXCELLENCE NOT JUST
COMPLIANCE. ALL RIGHT I MEAN
COMPLIANCE IS WHAT YOU DO
BECAUSE THE LAW TELLS YOU YOU
HAVE TO EXCELLENCE AND GOING
BEYOND THAT IS WHAT YOU DO TO
GET AN INCENTIVE. OF AND SO.
WHAT WE EXPECT EVERYONE TO YOU
KNOW PERFORM TO WHAT'S ALIGN TO
ALIGN WITH THE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AND POLICIES. THAT
SHOULDN'T ALONE LEAD TO A
FINANCIAL AWARD. INSTEAD WE
SHOULD REWARD PARTICIPANTS THAT
PURSUIT INNOVATIVE GOAL ABOVE
AND ON THE PRE EXISTING LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS AND CREATE GREATER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COMMUNITY
OPERA INTEGRATION PERSON
CENTERED PLANNING AND CHOICE.
PRIORITY SHOULD ALSO BE PLACED
ON RECENT LEGISLATIVE
INITIATIVES SUCH AS REDUCING
RELIANCE ON THE USE OF
INSTITUTES FOR MENTAL DISEASE
AND OTHER VERY RESTRICTIVE
SETTINGS. AS WELL AS REDUCING
THE SPENDING DISPARITIES THAT
EXIST BETWEEN CONSUMERS FROM
COMMUNITIES COLOR. A COMMUNITY
WERE WHITE AND BUT IN AND
ENGLISH SPEAKING CONSUMERS. WE
HAVE A FEW IDEAS OF THE
FRAMEWORK THAT COULD BE USED IN
PERFECT DEVELOPING PERFORMANCE
MEASURES. IN THE AREA OF
EMPLOYMENT WESLEY AND CINDY
BOTH SPOKE ABOUT THE LOW
EMPLOYMENT RATES OF PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AND WE REALLY
SHOULD BE- DRAFTING PERFORMANCE
MEASURES THAT RELATE TO
INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE WITH IDT TO PARTICIPATE
IN COMMUNITY COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT. IN
INDUSTRIES AND JOBS OF THEIR
CHOICE AND WE SHOULD WORK
TOWARD HASING OUT- SEGREGATED
SETTINGS THAT HAVE SUB MINIMUM
WAGE AS ROSY TALKED ABOUT NOT
BE WANTING TO BE PAID LESS THAN
SOMEONE ELSE FOR THE SAME JOB.
UP WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT WE
COULD CREATE. WE COULD LOOK
THROUGH A VARIETY OF FACTORS
INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS TO CHOOSE
THEIR IN INDUSTRY AND JOB FROM
SEVERAL OPTIONS. LOOKING FOR
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING ADEQUATE
TRAINING TO SUCCEED IN THEIR
JOB. AND TO LOOK TOWARD
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING ALL OF
THE NECESSARY SUPPORTS AND
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS AT
THEIR WORK PLACE. IN ADDITION
TO PERFORMANCE MEASURES RELATED
TO INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS AND COMPETITIVE AN
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT
PERFORMANCE MEASURES SEARCH
SHOULD ALSO ESTABLISH A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WORKING
IN SEGREGATED. SETTINGS WHERE
THEY MAKE SUB MINIMUM WAGE.
WHEN WE LOOK TO THE HOME BASED
COMMUNITY SETTINGS ROLE IN
RESIDENTIAL AND NON RESIDENTIAL
SETTINGS A WE CAN HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FOCUS ON PEOPLE
WITH IDT MAKING CHOICES- WITHIN
THE RULES ABOUT WHERE AND WITH
WHOM THEY WANT TO LIVE. OF
PERFORMANCE MEASURES FOR DAY
PROGRAMS SHOULD CAN MEASURE
WHETHER EACH INDIVIDUAL HAS
BEEN OFFERED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VISIT MULTIPLE PROGRAMS TO
OBSERVE THEM BEFORE THEY BEGIN
AND ONE. THIS SHOULD INCLUDE
PROGRAMS THAT WILL LINK IN.
SUPPORT THEM IN COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT AND
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
PEOPLE SPEND IN THE COMMUNITY
INSTEAD OF A SITE BASED
PROGRAMS. AS I MENTIONED
INSTITUTES FOR MENTAL DISEASE
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT-
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA'S
BECOME A LITTLE BIT OF A BROKEN
RECORD ON OVER THE YEARS IN NOT
WANTING THOSE THOSE USED SO
WHEN WE LOOK TO IT WAITING
INSTITUTE INSTITUTIONALIZATION
WERE VERY PLEASED WITH THE
PROGRESS THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
REGIONAL CENTERS. HAVE MADE TO
PHASE OUT THE USE OF THE STATE
OPERATED DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
AND WAS VERY EXCITED TO HEAR-DIRECTOR PART AND SAY WE HAVE
ONE PERSON LEFT THAT IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHING FOR
EVERYONE TO BE PROUD OF. TO DO
SO THOUGH WE NEED TO. BUILD A
SAFE A COMMUNITY SAFETY NET FOR
OUR INDIVIDUALS- AND- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT IS TROUBLING IS
THE RECENT AT DDS INITIATIVE
EXPANDING INSTITUTIONAL CARE AT
CANYON SPRINGS AND PORTIONS OF
PORTERFIELD DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER. IN THE INCREASING
RELIANCE ON ON AYE EMPTIES. WE
SHOULD HAVE PERFORMANCE
MEASURES ON THAT SS SUCCESS IN
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS PLACED IN
INSTITUTIONS- AS WELL AS
FOCUSING PREVENTATIVE ACTIONS
ON DIVERTING PLACEMENT IN AN
INSTITUTION IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND LASTLY SERVICE DISPARITIES-
DESPITE RECENT INCREASED
ATTENTION ON THE PURCHASE OF
SERVICE DISPARITIES. THEY
CONTINUE TO EXIST A REJECTION
OF THE SPENDING DISPARITY
SHOULD BE A NECESSARY COMPONENT
OF ANY OUTCOME DRIVEN PROGRAM.
SAID WE ARE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY AS HE
SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER- TO EAT YOU
KNOW REALLY LOOK AT PERFORMANCE
MEASURES AND USE THIS WINDOW
WELL- AND I HOPE THAT WITH THAT
WERE ABLE TO CRAFT SOME VERY-
GOOD PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT
BENEFIT THE LIVES OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT MR MODE. SO
AGAIN I APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOU
BEING HERE TODAY AND CAN ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I REALLY DO
LOOK FORWARD TO IS WHEN YOU
COME WITH SUGGESTIONS THAT
AFFECTS SOMETHING. NOT WHAT
YOU'VE DONE- YOU KNOW WHAT WHEN
WORKING ON PAST SUCCESSES BUT-
HOW WE ADVANCE TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER GOING FORWARD I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR INPUT. ON THAT
LEVEL- JUST TO SHARE WITH YOU.
I HAVE ELEVEN BILLS THAT WERE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING. THE
SPECIALTIES POPULATION LAST
YEAR AND ALL LEVEL OF THOSE
WERE KILLED THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE- JUSTICE JUST TO.
THIS SO WE ARE TRYING TO MOVE
FORTY PLUS BUT IN INTEGRATED
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
SEVERAL OF THE FACTORS THAT YOU
JUST. MENTIONED WILL CONTINUE
TO GO FORWARD WITH LEGISLATION
BUT- WASN'T FROM LACK OF EFFORT
ON. INPUT FROM THE COMMITTEE
AND ALL OF YOU ON SO. I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE COMING FORWARD.
AND SHARING WITH US SO YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. AND THE LOOK FOR
TO FURTHER- COLLABORATION GOING
TOWARDS THANK YOU YOU HAVE. SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD TO.
KIND OF THE MEAT AND POTATOES
OF THIS HEARING IN THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS.
WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU TO LINE UP
OVER HERE. AND COME TO THE MIKE
AND SHARE WITH US. HI YOUR
CONCERNS OR OF THINGS THAT-
YOU'D LIKE TO ADDRESS FOR THE
COMMITTEE I'M GOING TO ASK YOU
TO BE LIMITED TO ABOUT TWO
MINUTES. IF YOU CAN IF NOT I
WILL ASK YOU TO WRAP UP BUT
WHAT I NEED FOR HOUSTON STATE
YOUR NAME. WHERE YOU'RE FROM
AND WHO YOU'RE REPRESENTING SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE THAT FOR THE
RECORD SIR. DR SEVEN BEDS. DR
SEVEN BEDS CHAIR OF THE BOARD
OF THE CONNECTIONS FOR LIFE
AGENCY- SUPPORTED AN
INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES
AGENCY. OF ALSO FORMA AND
RETIRED CINEMA HEALTH DIRECTOR.
SOME LESSONS LEARNED ON THE
CLOSURE OF THIS ONE ON A CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER HOSPITALS
ARE OUR FRIENDS THE LOCAL
HOSPITALS THEY'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT CLIENTS HAVING
TO BE HOSPITALIZED BECAUSE
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES WERE
OT AVAILABLE- SO. I AM SO
APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR COMMITTEE
TO GO OUT AND DO THE LISTENING
TO A I THINK THE NEXT STEP IN
ADDRESSING ALL THE COMPLEXITIES
THAT YOU'VE HEARD IS TO CONVENE
PARTNERS AROUND THE TABLE WHO
ARE IMPACTED AND THAT INCLUDES
HOSPITALS TO GO FORWARD. AND
SAY WHAT CAN WE DO TOGETHER FOR
INSTANCE OTHER STATES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED INTEGRATED SERVICES
WE HEART THAT OFTEN. FROM OF
BOTH PARENTS AND ADVOCATES AS
WELL AS- CONSISTENCY OF
SERVICES TO REDUCE THE TURN
OVER AN INCREASE THE WORK FORCE
AS A ACTUALLY AVAILABLE FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES THANK
YOU. PETTY A PLAYER LOCAL
SACRAMENTO FROM HOUSING NOW I'M
ALSO HOUSING SPECIALIST FOR
DIFFERENT SUPPORTED LIVING
AGENCIES INCLUDING CONNECTIONS
FOR LIFE. AND SO I AM HERE IN A
I'M ALSO CONSULTANT FOR WENT TO
MEN HOUSING ALLIANCE SO HOUSING
IS VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO ME AND
IT'S- YOU WE KNOW THERE'S A
CRISIS FOR HOUSING IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. FOLKS WITH ID DE
IT'S A CRISIS WITHIN A CRISIS
IS REALLY EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
THAT WE ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WE'VE GOT PEOPLE AS YOU HEARD
PEOPLE THAT ARE HOMELESS THAT
ARE THAT HAVE ID DE CONTRARY TO
POPULAR BELIEF THAT THERE ARE
NO PEOPLE WITH ID D. THERE ARE
HOMELESS. IN MY REAL MY PAID
JOB I AM A I WORK AT SACRAMENTO
SELF HELP HOUSING AND I LOOK
FOR HOUSES THE HOUSE HOMELESS
FOLKS AND SO I SEE THE
POPULATION THAT WE COME BY AND
THERE ARE PEOPLE WITH ID DE.
THAT WE ARE SERVING AND SO WE
DO NEED TO DO RENTAL SUBSIDIES
MAYBE SUPPLEMENT SSI SOMETHING
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON FIXED
INCOMES AND SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME THEY'RE PRICED
OUT YOU KNOW THEY'RE PRICED
OUT. I JUST NEED TO EMPHASIZE
THAT SO OF HAVING A DEDICATED
FUNDING SOURCE FOR HOUSING FOR
THIS POPULATION WOULD BE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I THINK.
AND AS WELL AS THE RENTAL
SUBSIDIES THAT I TALKED ABOUT
AND YOU ALSO HEARD FROM OUR
SELF ADVOCATES ABOUT THE LIVING
IN US UNSAFE NEIGHBORHOODS I
USED TO PRIDE MYSELF IN LOOKING
FOR HOUSING AND SAFE AND DECENT
NEIGHBORHOODS. IT'S REALLY HARD
TO FIND THAT WERE SOMEONE CAN
AFFORD IT AND IT'S REALLY A SAD
SITUATION CALIFORNIA I DIDN'T
JUST STRESSING ABOUT THE NEED
FOR HOUSING IN ANYTHING YOU
NEED- ANY HOUSING ACT
INFORMATION YOU LIKE. FEEL FREE
TO REACH OUT TO US I HAVE SOME
PAMPHLETS ALL LEAVE HERE FOR
LETTERMAN HOUSING ALLIANCE AND
WHAT WERE THERE TO HELP YOU OUT
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DO AND-
FOR HAVING THIS COMMITTEE.
HELLO THERE MY NAME TIMING
MARKETS THEM FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I AM CURRENTLY REPRESENTING
OUR CALIFORNIA- DISSECTING THE
CHAIN COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK THEY'VE DONE. ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIANS WENT TO
LECTURE SLASH DEPLOYMENT TO THE
BODIES. THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK AND HELP YOU KEEP GOOD.
KEEP UP THE FIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU MISS SOMEONE FRAZIER FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY AND
ALL THE WORK YOU'VE BEEN DOING
OUR IN THE FUTURE- COUPLE QUICK
COMMENTS FROM WHAT I HEARD- ONE
IS ABOUT THIS THE WHOLE CONCEPT
OF AUDIT. THERE'S A FOREMAN
SADA TO THERE'S FINANCIAL
AUDITS AND IT WAS REPRESENTED
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING REALLY
EASY HE CAN YOU KNOW THAT YOU
CAN DO IN ONE DAY INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT INCREDIBLY TIME
CONSUMING THE COST ABOUT US
ABOUT SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
PROGRAM- FOR FINANCIAL AUDIT-
SO IT'S NOT AN EASY PROCESS IS
VERY EXPENSIVE AND- AND WHEN
YOU HAVE A- A PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN. THEN SYSTEMATICALLY
STAR FOR GENERATION- HAVE
IMPROVE WHERE THEY SPEND EVERY
CENT IS DIFFICULT SOMETIMES-
REGARDING OUR REGIONAL CENTER
REGIS SORT OF THE EAST BAY THEY
DO A FANTASTIC JOB- SO I'M NOT
A AFRAID HERE TODAY THAT TO SAY
YOU KNOW HOW THEIR PERFORMANCES
THEY DO A GREAT JOB THEY TREAT
US GREAT- BUT THEY'RE NOT
COMPLYING WITH THEIR CASE LOAD.
RULES BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH FUNDING- SO IT'S A
SYSTEM WIDE WE HAVE THESE
ISSUES- I WISH SEVERAL MOMENTS
THE SERVER IS FATHER APPEAR. WE
CAME IN AND OUT TOGETHER- IT'S
ALL ABOUT THE RATE STUDY. LIKE
INTEREST YEAH BUT ABOUT THINGS
THAT WHAT ABOUT STUDY. I HAD.
THIS IS A FIFTY YEAR. SO IT'S
THE RACE THAT IN A MOMENT ISN'T
THAT THE SOME THING ARE TURNING
OUR PER AND WE HAVE A PROGRAMS
IN YOUR JUST IS 50% AS ALL
SYMPTOMS OF THE RATES AND NOT
BE ABLE TO PAY OUR PEOPLE AND
COMPETING WITH IN AND OUT
BURGER FOR STAFF- AND SO. AS AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN FIND THE RATE
STUDY THE BETTER OFF WE'LL BE-
I ALSO LIKED- THOSE A COUPLE
COMMENTS ABOUT TRANSPORTATION-
AND WITHOUT TRANSPORTATION THE
WHOLE- INTEGRATION INCLUSION IN
CHOICE IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO
RETALIATION TO MAKE ALL THIS
HAPPEN IS NOT GONNA HAPPEN- SO
MORE FUNDING FOR THAT A GOOD
FUNDING AND SAFE-
TRANSPORTATION IS REALLY KEY TO
EVERYTHING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO LIVE FOR THE FUTURE. SO
FRAZIER I'M HERE REPRESENTING
WILL STAND FOR REPRESENTING
CALTRAIN DISPLAY SERVICES SO
SHE SHOULD TODAY. THE RISE IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH- SOMEONE OR
MULLIN AND WEBER AND YOUR
COMMENTS RELATED TO THE WINDOW
FUNDING. WE'RE IN GOOD TIMES
NOW- HISTORICALLY WE ALWAYS
LAG. GET HAMMERED FIRST BILLION
DOLLARS BACK LAST INTO THE
DOLLARS COMING BACK SHOULD COME
IN SOONER STYLE BE HELPFUL
ABSOLUTELY ON THE RATE MODEL WE
IMPLEMENT THE RATE MODEL WE
START IN THAT PROCESS.
OTHERWISE IT'S ACTUALLY NOT
GOING TO SIT ON A SHELF WAS
GONNA OCCUPY A LARGE CHUNK OF
THE GOOGLE CLOUD SO MORE- TO
THAT OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGE
ACCESS WHICH IS WORKFORCE. WE
NEED TO BUILD A HIGHER RETAIN
STAFF. IN THE BAY AREA WITH THE
LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE IS BEING SO
HIGH THAT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
SAYS BY THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
OF FOLKS GETTING THE SERVICES
THEY WANT. A WELL QUALIFIED
WORKFORCE IS ONE OF THE
STRONGEST WAYS TO ACTUALLY GET
HEALTH AND SAFETY IN THE
SERVICES OF PEOPLE WANT THAT'S
WHAT QUALITY STARTS WITH OUR
WORK FIRST- REALLY NEED. HONG
AT AN. THE DOOR I LOVE SO WHERE
CONVERSATION I DIDN'T CATCH
TODAY BY THERE WAS A WE
FIFTEEN. CONVERSATION IS AN
ACTION. LET'S NOT ACTIONABLE.
DOESN'T LEAD TO A TO RESULT
WHEN YOU SOME TO MOVE DOWN THAT
JET DOWN THAT ROAD. WE REALLY
FEEL WAY TO DO IT AND DO IT
SOON SO. AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR SUPPORT IN THE PAST
IN. THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR DOING
THIS TODAY IT WAS VERY
INFORMATIVE. MY NAME IS KELLY
MCMILLAN AND I REPRESENT REYES
CARE RIGHT SPRINGS- CENTERS
WERE THE LARGEST PRIVATE
PROVIDER FOR ICF. CALIFORNIAN
COUNTRY. AND TO MENTION HERE A
FEW TIMES ABOUT THE BUDGET
OPPORTUNITIES AND SO. AS YOU
KNOW ICF DDS WERE THE FIRST
PROVIDERS TO EVER PRO- PAY A
PROVIDER TAX TO HELP OFFSET THE
GENERAL FUND. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY- THE RATES HAVE
BEEN FROZEN FOR TWELVE YEARS.
AND PROVIDERS HAVE NO OTHER WAY
TO RAISE REVENUES BECAUSE THEY
DEPEND ON MEDI CAL PROGRAM. AND
DUE TO THIS RATE FREEZE RISE
CARE- RIGHT SPRINGS HEALTH HAS
HAD TO PUT IN A- PUT IN THE
POSITION OF ACTUALLY CLOSING.
AND CONSOLIDATING OUR HOMES
ESPECIALLY IN THE HIGH MARKET
LOCATIONS THAT WAS MENTIONED
TODAY AS WELL. AND EVEN WITH
THE RATE- ADD ONS FOR CERTAIN
MANDATORY LABOR AND REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS THAT ESCALATING
COSTS AND- TREMENDOUS PRESSURE
IT TO PROVIDE IT PUTTING
PRESSURE TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE
THE QUALITY SERVICES WE NEED TO
DO. IF THE RATE FREEZE IS
MAINTAINED A RIGHT AND A RATE
ADJUSTMENT TO KEEP AT LEAST UP
TO CPI'S NOT PROVIDED. A RISK
OF JEOPARDIZING THE SERVICES.
SO AS MEN FOR THE TIMING IS NOW
AND I MEAN OF OUR BUDGET
SURPLUS WE WOULD LIKE YOU TO
CONSIDER. TRIMMING THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT MEDI CAL RIPKEN
FREEZE AND JUST THE RATE TO
FIFTEEN PERCENT. AT THE
PHILIPS. REASONABLE THE TWELVE
YEAR RATE FREEZE. THANK. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR MY REPRESENT
CLIENTS PRETTY PEOPLE THE
KNOCKS ON THE- TO. WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO THIS COMMUNITY AND HEARING
US OUT OF JUST A COUPLE POINTS
I'M TO GO BEYOND DISCUSSION
TODAY. AND THAT IS AFTER- THREE
YEARS OF STUDY WE DISCOVERED
THAT THE SYSTEM IS UNDER FUNDED
BY A ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION-
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION- HAS BEEN INVESTED
THANKS IN GREAT PART TO YOUR
ADVOCACY- HOWEVER WE- DO NEED.
TO URGE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CONTINUE PUSHING ON WITH THIS
I'M JUST RECENTLY UPDATED DAY
PROGRAM IN HAYWARD- ANNOUNCES
CLOSURE. AND MARCH WHICH WILL
DISPLACE THIRTY FIVE
INDIVIDUALS FROM THEIR
SERVICES- AND AS WE KNOW THE A
REPLACEMENT SERVICES WILL NOT
BE AT ANY CHEAPER. ADDITIONALLY
I WANTED TO ADD- THE RECOGNIZED
US SERVICES IN JANUARY BUDGET-
I LS AND INFANT DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES- ALTHOUGH WE'RE- VERY
GRATEFUL THAT THOSE ARE
RECOGNIZED- AND- GOING TO BE
GIVEN AN INCREASE. AT THE FACT
THAT THE INCREASE WILL NOT
TAKE- BE ENACTED FOR ANOTHER
YEAR- CONTRADICTS THE
RECOGNIZED THE RECOGNITION- FOR
THE NEED OF THAT INCREASE.
THANK YOU. HELLO CHAIRMAN FOR
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND TEN
AT TEN THE COMMITTEE HEARING MY
NAME'S BRIAN HOOKER I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND FROM WHAT
I CAN SEE. WORKFORCE SYSTEM IN
GENERAL- HEARD A LOT OF GREAT
COMMENTS HERE FROM THE
PANELISTS- AND SOME GREAT
REPORTS. AND I JUST WANTED TO
REMIND YOU AND OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE TO PUSH FORWARD
WITH YOUR EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES FOR THE
NEEDY COMMUNITY. NOT FORGET THE
GOOD WORK WORK FIRST DEVELOP
SYSTEM DOING. FOR THE START OF
POPULATION AS WELL AS LOOK
LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS AND
SOLANO COUNTY RECIPIENTS OF A-
DISABILITY EMPLOYMENT
ACCELERATOR GRANT AND WE WERE
VERY SUCCESSFUL WITH THAT
PROGRAM. FUNDED BY EDT AND WITH
THE OF DISCRETION FUNDING WE'RE
ABLE TO SUCCESSFUL PLACE
INDIVIDUALS- OF THE IDEA YOU
COMMUNITY. LIKE JUSTIN AND
WESLEY THAT WE HEARD EARLIER
WHO'VE ATTAIN DEGREES OR EVEN
AND ADVANCED DEGREES- OR
INDUSTRY RECOGNIZED
CERTIFICATION BUT ARE UNABLE TO
ATTAIN THAT APPOINTMENT. WE
WENT STUDY FOR- WITHOUT THE
HELP OF THIS DISCRETIONARY
FUNDS TO THE STATE. IT WILL BE
WILL TO DO THIS WILL. ON THE
WORK FORCE TO BOARD US LOW.
HAVE ALL SERVICE COMMITTEE FOR
NUMBER YEARS BUT BY IN
RECOGNITION OF THE STATE
WORKFORCE PLANNING COMPLIANCE
WITH OUR LOCAL A REBEL PLUS. UP
TO DO THIS AT WE HAVE TO. ON A
ON HOW TO BETTER WORK WITH ID
DO YOU CAN. TO THE RECOGNIZE
CHALLENGE THAT ARE SO FORTH
THEM. AND WHAT THEIR ARE IN.
AND AS A SYSTEM A WHOLE SO
PLEASE KEEP THE WORK FOR SYSTEM
IN MIND WE CAN BY THE
WRAPAROUND AND TRANSPORTATION
SUPPORTS THAT ARE NEEDED TO
HELP THESE INDIVIDUALS ATTAIN-
EMPLOYMENT. THANK YOU. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MR FRAZIER HI MY
NAME IS TO LEAVE AS THE ARI AND
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTED LIVING
NETWORK. AS WELL THE CALIFORNIA
RESPITE ASSOCIATION- I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THE LISTENING SESSIONS OVER THE
PAST YEAR FOR YOUR WORK IN
LEADERSHIP- AND DRIVING THESE.
THESE ISSUES OUT INTO THE FRONT
SO THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND- FROM
A MUCH MORE HOLISTIC
PERSPECTIVE WHAT'S GOING ON IN
OUR COMMUNITY- I WE LOOK
FORWARD ADD TO MOVING THE
SYSTEM FORWARD WITH THE RATES
AT. THE RATE STUDY. CONTACT THE
PERSON. VISION AS PROJECT THAT
CALVET TO PUT IN LIVING NETWORK
WAS GRANTED FUNDING FROM THE
STATE COUNCIL- WE'RE MOVING
WEAR. REVEALING TALKING TOO
MANY PARENTS ADVOCATES- GETTING
TOGETHER IN FEBRUARY SO THAT WE
CAN START THE STUDY- IF YOU
WANT MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THAT I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
PASS ALONG MY CARD AND YOU CAN
SPEAK WITH THE- FOLKS. THAT ARE
RUNNING THAT STUDY- WE ALSO
HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING- INSTRUCTOR
ISSUE IOS. THAT WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVEN THOUGH THE
DDS HAS PUT FORWARD ADDITIONAL
EIGHT POINT 2% FUNDING- TO
START IN JUNE. OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE ARE ASKING THAT THE
BUDGET DOES PASS WITH THAT
PROPOSAL IF WE CAN GET THAT
RIGHT TO ACTIVATE IT BACK TO
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY- SO WE'RE
ASKING ALL THE LEGISLATURE IF
THEY CAN. REVIEW THAT AND ONCE
THAT COMES UP IF THEY CAN
ADVOCATE FOR THAT THROUGH THE
DDS- AND SO AGAIN AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND REALLY A-
COMING OUT TODAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY
WESTLING I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES. AND I HAVE THE
HONOR OF REPRESENTING ALL
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS IN
THE STATE AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
AS WE HEARD THIS AFTERNOON.
DURING CREDIBLE DEDICATED STAFF
FIRST AND FOREMOST MISTER
FRAZIER I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO GET TO KNOW
US AND GETTING TO KNOW OUR
COMMUNITIES. IT'S NO SMALL FEAT
TO TRAVERSE UP AND DOWN THE
STATE HOLDING HEARINGS AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT AND APPRECIATE
IT. BECAUSE IT REALLY PROVIDES
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T GET TO
SACRAMENTO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TELL THEIR STORIES- AND AS WE
SAW HERE TODAY. IT IS THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SERVED BY THE
SYSTEM AND THEIR FAMILIES WHO
HAVE THE MOST POWERFUL STORIES
TO TELL. THIS SYSTEM AS
DIRECTOR BRIDGMAN POINTED OUT
HAS HIT A- TIPPING POINT A
MILESTONE IF YOU WILL. IN TERMS
OF WE ARE EIGHT. 101% COMMUNITY
BASED SYSTEM IN TERMS OF THE
LONG TERM PLANS FOR PEOPLE WE
NO LONGER HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESIDING IN DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS AS THEIR FOREVER HOMES.
AND THIS PRESENTS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO THINK ABOUT THE
NEXT FIFTY YEARS OF THE SYSTEM.
WE KNOW THAT THE SYSTEM IS
SEEKS TO PROVIDE PEOPLE WITH
THREE BIG THINGS FIRST EARLY
INTERVENTION TO HELP YOUNG
CHILDREN CATCH UP.
DEVELOPMENTALLY TO THEIR SAME
AGE PEERS SECOND FAMILY SUPPORT
SYSTEMS AND SERVICES TO HELP
FAMILIES WHO. ARE MAINTAINING A
CHILD AT HOME TO BE ABLE TO DO
SO AND I APPRECIATE IN THE
SURVEY RESULTS. SOME OF THE
NOTATIONS ABOUT THOSE SERVICES
THAT ARE MOST IMPORTANT TO
FAMILIES THAT ENABLE THEM TO
CONTINUE WORKING AND BALANCING
THE CARE NEEDS OF THEIR CHILD.
AND THIRD WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
WORKING TOWARDS HELPING PEOPLE.
WHO ARE ADULTS TO ACHIEVE THE
GREATEST LEVEL OF INDEPENDENCE
POSSIBLE. AND WE HEARD TODAY
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
EMPLOYMENT TRANSPORTATION AND
OVERALL THESE THINGS LEAD TO
COMMUNITY MEMBERSHIP. AND
THAT'S THE BIGGEST GOAL OF THE
SYSTEM HELPING PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. TO
BECOME FULL MEMBERS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND TO ENGAGE THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO RECOGNIZE THEM
AS FULL MEMBERS. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
THE REGIONAL CENTERS LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE THE NEEDS
OF THE SYSTEM WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS WORK TO BE DONE. AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION THANK YOU. THANK ANY
OTHER MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE STOP OF THE MIKE
FROM CALM. OKAY SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND PARTICIPATING IN THE
HEARING. HELLO OF MEETING ALL
OF YOU. I WANT TO AGAIN THANK
ARM ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF WALDRON
MULLIN MEDINA AND WEBER TODAY
FOR SHARING THIS. HEARING TODAY.
I WANT TO GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY BUT THEY'RE SO BUSY
DOING OTHER MEETINGS AND THAT
HIS YOU DON'T REALIZE HOW MUCH
IT MEANT FOR THEM TO BE HERE.
WITH A BUSY SCHEDULE SPENDING
THE TIME THAT THEY DID IT'S
AMAZING. HI I THANK EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THEM FOR THAT. HOME
I'D LIKE TO BID ALL OF YOU CAN
BUY. JUST SAYING I'M VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOU ALL TO BE HERE
TODAY. FEW THINGS THAT IN THE
CLOSING. THE SUPPORT SYSTEM FOR
THOSE WITH DISABILITIES HAS
ENTERED FLUCTUATING LEVELS OF
SUPPORT FROM THE STATE OVER THE
PAST DECADE. PAST SEVERAL
DECADES. YET THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHITE EIGHTY D.
CONTINUES TO RISE. OVER THE
LAST DECADE WE HAVE SEEN OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW CONSUMERS.
ENTER THE SYSTEM. MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOW THESE ARE
CALIFORNIANS. NOW BEING
SERVICED AND WE SHOULD EXPECT
TO SEE MORE. WE HAVE WE HAVE
SEEN A FEW GAINS IN OUR STATE
BUDGETS TO MEET THESE NEEDS AND
THEY'VE BEEN INCREMENTAL THE
BEST. PARTICULAR THE BUDGET WE
PASSED LAST YEAR DOES INCLUDE A
RATE INCREASE FOR SUS SERVICE
PROVIDERS. HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ARE GOING INTO THE
SYSTEM. THERE ARE CURRENT
PROPOSALS O EXTEND SOME OF
THESE INCREASES AND INTRODUCE
FISCAL ROOF REFORMS. BUT THE
STATE STILL HAS NOT DONE NEARLY
ENOUGH. THE ADD COMMUNITIES
BEING LEFT BEHIND WHILE OTHER
AREAS OF SOCIAL SAFETY NETS ARE
BEING FULLY FUNDED. IT'S NOT
FAIR. THE INCREASE FUNDING FOR
IT PROGRAMS THE BUDGET PROVIDED
HAS ONLY BEEN IN EFFECT FOR
TWENTY EIGHT DAYS. AND THE FACT
THAT IS SOME PROGRAMS WERE NOT
ABLE TO WAIT. FOR THAT- THE
TIME THAT WE TALKED ABOUT. I'VE
HEARD OF CLOSURES IN MY AREA
AND I'M SURE OTHERS ARE ALSO
AFFECTED. THAT'S JUST WRONG. I
HAVE TO GO BACK TO A MOTHER
THAT I- WORKED ON HER CASE. AND
SHE SAID IT WAS EASIER FOR HER
TO GO ON WELFARE THAN TRYING TO
FIND ADVOCATE SO THAT SHE COULD
FIGHT FULL TIME FOR HER SON.
SHE WAS WILLING TO GIVE UP HER
CAREER. TO PROVIDE A OF FUTURE
LIFE FOR HER SON. THAT'S WRONG.
WE ALSO HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE MORTALITY RATE ON
MARRIAGE IS ABOUT 85% WHEN YOU
HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS FAMILY. WE
NEED TO DO BETTER TO SUPPORT
THAT FAMILY UNIT. WHERE
PROGRAMS ARE STILL STRUGGLING
BECAUSE OUR STATE. LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR'S AND NOW OUR
CURRENT LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR HAVE ONLY GIVEN THE
SYSTEM TO INCREASES. IN THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS. DESPITE THE
COMPLETION OF THE RATE STUDY.
WHICH CONFIRMS A CURRENT BUDGET
FOR OF SHORTFALL OF AT LEAST
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
WISHES THAT'S DEBATABLE COULD
BE AND SHOULD BE PROBABLY MORE
THERE'S STILL NO STRATEGIC PLAN
TO PHASE IN ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS.
FOR THE PAST FEW YEARS THE IDT
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN ASKED TO
WAIT. FOR AN AUDIT TO FINISH
I'M FOR RACE DAY TO BE
COMPLETED. AND FOR SOME FUNDING
TO TAKE IN FACT. I'M HERE TO
SAY. THERE'S NO MORE REASON TO
WAIT. IT'S TIME TO. MAKE
PROGRESS WE NEED TO MAKE A PLAN
AND WE NEED TO MAKE IT NOW.
UNTIL WE HAVE A PLAN WE CAN
SIMPLY WE CAN'T SIMPLY ABANDON
THESE PROGRAMS A WRIST SOME
FALLING APART BECAUSE WE THINK.
THERE MIGHT BE CHANGES IN THE
SYSTEM THREE YEARS FROM NOW.
THE DEPARTMENT OF ALMOST
SERVICES AS FINALIZE A RACE
STUDY TO ADDRESS SOME SERIOUS
FLAWS. AND WE ALL SEE THE
POTENTIAL OF A PATH FOR A VERY
PROMISING PATH FORWARD BUT AS
MY MEMBERS OF THE KNOWLEDGE TO.
NEEDS TO BE NOW. IT IS OUR JOB
TO PROVIDE THE OVERSIGHT
NECESSARY TO COMPEL THE
CREATION OF A PLAN EXCUSE ME
AND INVEST THE RESOURCES INTO
THIS COMMUNITY. THREE STUDY
SAYS WE ARE UNDER FUNDING THIS
SYSTEM. AND SO WHAT'S ARE ALL
THAT. WE KNOW WE'RE
UNDERFUNDING IT. WE HAVE PEOPLE
THAT SAY THAT THEY CAN UTILIZE
THE MONEY IN A WAY THAT WE CAN
VALUE IT. ELIZABETH FOR. WE DO
DO WE DO TO THAT NEED TO MAKE
THAT. WE NEED TO DO MORE. AND I
KNOW EACH OF YOU WILL HELP US
GET THERE. I ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
BECAUSE I WOULD INCOME I WAS IN
YOUR SHOES. I'D OF FLIPPED TO
TELL YOU THE TRUTH YOU GUYS
HAVE THE PATIENCE OF JOB AND
THANK GOD FOR THAT. I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE. THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FROM- THE SEALS
SPECIAL EFFECTS WAS HERE DAVID
SOLO- IN SUPPORT. IS BEEN
AMAZING INDIVIDUAL ON THAT END-
IN SPECIAL OLYMPICS. HI AGAIN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOUSTON. THANKS
FOR HANGING IN THERE. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HIS. IN THIS WORLD
IN SACRAMENTO THE SCRIPT THE
SQUEAKY WHEEL GETS THE GREASE
THE MOST. STARTS WE CAN PEOPLE.
STARTS WEAKENED. YOU KNOW IT'S
TIME IT'S TIME SO YOUR
REPRESENTATIVE. JUST MAKE THEM
ACCOUNTABLE WHY AND HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO SUPPORT YOU. I ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND THANK
LISA FROM THE EAST BAY REGIONAL
CENTER WHO'S HERE. SHE COMES
THESE EVENTS RELIGIOUSLY
HEARING EUROPE THIS IS AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HEARING
INPUT. FROM THE COMMUNITY GOING
OUT AND LISTENING JUST LIKE
WHAT WE'RE DOING. LET'S SEE.
FOR THAT I APPLAUD YOU THANK
YOU. YOU KNOW THAT WE'RE HERE
FOR YOU WE NEED YOU KNOW THAT
MY STAFF WILL BE HERE AT YOUR
BECK AND CALL WHEN YOU NEED US-
I WILL SAY THAT I THINK THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
INFORMATION. BROUGHT TO THE ID
POPULATION OF HOW THEY CAN IF
THEY FEEL THAT THEY'RE NOT
BEING. ERIC RECEIVING THEM THE-
SERVICES THAT THEY- DESERVE OR
NEED THEY NEED TO HAVE THAT
OUTLET TO WERE WHO THEY CAN GO
TO AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
HEARD. WITH THAT. WILL MOVE
FORWARD- A KNOWLEDGE IN THAT
THERE DOES NEED TO BE
LEGISLATION. ADVANCED BUT WE
CAN'T DO THIS ALONE THIS
LEGISLATURE CAN'T DO THIS
WITHOUT YOU. OKAY SO LET'S
PARTNER UP. AND IN THIS BUDGET
CYCLE PLEASE ACKNOWLEDGE TO
YOUR. IT'S TIME IT IS TIME AND
PROMISES WERE MADE THOSE
PROMISES NEED TO BE KEPT. WITH
THAT I A BID YOU A DO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND THIS
HEARINGS.